ganz schön früher oder hier guck mal 845 so früh sind wir normalerweise nie habe ich
den stream auf der richtigen kategorie gucken ja hier just chatted schatz chatigen oder stream
richtig los geht muss mal kurz meine wöchentliche sache gucken auf github was trennt weekly nicht
nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht
nicht nicht ich nicht mich bisschen ist das mich nicht schockt mich auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht
auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht okay da ist nichts dabei diese woche was
mich irgendwie auch nur ansatz weil sie übrigens so viel zu früh noch so beides wird es wird
jetzt eine viertelstunde unterschied ausmachen bin gerade aufgestanden so wie es einem da halt
so geht aber ich muss mal kurz mails was gucken was machen denn die ganzen sponsoring dudes nachdem
das genschen sponsoring also gut angekommen ist werde ich auf diese art und weise sicherlich noch
mehr vorlesen in nächster zeit mich hat ein china chinesen wie nennt man das so so so klein geräte
elektro kleinen teil geräte hersteller angefragt wie es aussieht mit gerät vorstellen also quasi so
ein hersteller der handy halterung macht netzteile macht und irgendwie sowas da bin ich mir nicht so
sicher ob ich das machen soll ich habe zwar selbst von denen ein paar aber das ist preislich nicht so
interessant und naja was soll ich dazu erzählen soll ich 60 sekunden eine handy halterung zeigen
oder was martin inoffiziell musik erste chance
nachricht erst wollen ja es ist glaube ich relativ relativ sinnlos sowas zu machen der
gerät und der gerät ist auch immer vor dem chef vor dem chef im geschäft oder irgendwie so also
das sponsoring von dem china chinesen elektronik teilehersteller werde ich nicht machen ob es ab
end dankeschön zwei monate subskription massive subs ja mein elsa
ich muss heute
noch was gefällt mir gerade ein ich muss noch was überweisen ans finanzamt ich muss noch elektriker
rechnung bezahlen und ich muss noch zahnarzt rechnung bezahlen muss ich mal machen c++ updates
die es gab doch jetzt letztens ein neues c eine neue c version oder doch habe ich doch letztens
gelesen c 2022 oder sowas der sich im vergleich zu c++
tatsächlich irgendwie noch ganz sinnig liest allerdings sind da wohl auch haben da irgendwelche
c++ leute ihre hände mit drin das heißt demnächst arte das auch aus allerdings ist das ja immer
gerade bei solchen standards nicht so das großartige problem das dauerte 20 jahre bis das
irgendwo umgesetzt ist genauso wie c++ nie herder falls loswerden wird schon über die neueste exchange
lücke was ist da zeige ich mal habe ich nicht mitgekriegt bsi warten da wenn sogar das bsi vorwarnen bin ich aber ganz schön langsam
dass wir mitkriegen moment leute sekunde sekunde zero day attack mit dem microsoft exchange
sicherheits patches fehlen naja gut da freuen sich jetzt alle die exchange über über office 365
verwenden ja doch ist wahrscheinlich exchange outlook 365 die freuen sich jetzt weil die wahrscheinlich
nicht das problem haben ok sicherheitsbausch da war das das angreifen derzeit zwar doppelt naja das ist
dann eine zero zero day lücke
Ein Workaround.
Okay, also was muss man machen?
Ihnen zufolge sollen Angreifer aus dem China-Chinesischen Umfeld Exchange-Server erfolgreich...
Was sonst?
Ich habe davon abgesehen, vielleicht haben die auch einfach nur den VPN verwendet.
Aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die China-Chinesen gleich wieder am Start sind.
Ich habe gehört, der Rockstar-Hackerman wurde angeblich festgenommen.
Mittlerweile haben weitere Sicherheitsvorteile darunter auch Trend-Micro-Serial.
Ähm, Details sind bislang kaum veröffentlicht.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Was sagt denn Microsoft dazu?
Okay, was muss man...
Alter, was ist das wieder für komisches, obskures...
Was muss man machen?
Um Systeme aber jetzt schon zu schützen, haben die Sicherheitsvorteile ein Temporal...
Um Anfragen zum Einladen der Attacke zu blocken.
Dafür müssen Admins unter Auto-Discovery im Tab Ur-Rewrite eine Request-Blocking-Regel...
Ach so, das ist das Exchange, irgendwelche Sachen...
Wisst ihr, eine Sache regt mich generell bei Server-Software auf, oder generell bei vieler Software auf,
wenn die automatisch irgendwelche Dinger macht, die ich nicht explizit eingeschaltet habe.
Oder wenn Software zu sehr mitdenkt, und zwar dann irgendwas als Ergebnis rauskommt, was ich eigentlich gar nicht haben will.
Mit folgendem PowerShell-Kommando können Admins prüfen, ob die Server bereits kompromittiert sind.
Naja, solange die irgendwelche Hinterlassenschaften haben.
Ah, es gibt sogar ein offizielles Shell-Skript, was den Workaround...
Warum ist das nicht? Warum ist das hier?
Genaue Erklärung gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Okay, authentifizierte Angreifer kann Remote das da triggern.
Und das da gibt es keine großartigen...
Na gut, das sind ja nur die Erklärungen.
Keine großartigen Erklärungen zu...
8,8 von 8,3. Alles klar.
Ja, viele Infos gibt es dazu tatsächlich noch nicht.
Naja, ist halt mal wieder irgendwelcher Microsoft-Shit.
Generell, ganz im Ernst, alles was ich bisher mitbekommen habe von dem Microsoft-Support, ist auch wirklich richtig schlecht gewesen.
Also, wir haben ja relativ viel auf der Arbeit, was Azure angeht von Microsoft.
Und wir haben auch jede Menge Support-Geschichten und sonst was von Microsoft.
Und jedes Mal, wenn du bei denen was an...
Wenn du dort irgendeine Support-Anfrage machst, dann läuft es eigentlich darauf raus, dass es keine hilfreiche Antwort gibt.
Naja, wenn du Support bei denen gekauft hast, kriegst du auch Support.
Da kannst du bei denen ein Ticket aufmachen oder Support-Anfrage stellen.
Also, du stellst bei Microsoft eine Support-Anfrage.
Was weiß ich? Ja, keine Ahnung hier.
Warum hängt mein Service beim Starten?
So, irgendwas, ja.
Und dann bekommst du eine Antwort.
Wir haben den Eindruck, dass sie Probleme haben.
Den Service.
Haben sie schon mal versucht, den Service zu starten?
Sollte diese Antwort ihnen geholfen haben, bitte Ticket schließen.
So, ungefähr so auf diesem Niveau bewegt sich dann die erste Antwort.
Und warum ist das so?
Weil nicht die Hilfe bezahlt wird, sondern Reaktionszeiten bezahlt werden.
Das ist so ein typischer Fall von falschen Anreizen irgendwie.
Generell ist es total bescheuert.
Es ist gang und gäbe.
Ich weiß, es ist gang und gäbe.
Aber es ist total bescheuert für...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Reine Reaktion zu bezahlen.
Weil reine Reaktion kann auch sein.
Hallo, wir haben das Ticket erhalten und weitergeleitet.
Oder...
Hallo, ich bin Second-Level-Techniker und bitte starten Sie den Service noch.
Das ist halt alles Reaktion.
Deswegen schreibt Microsoft innerhalb von zwei, drei Stunden so ein absolut unsinniges Kommentar rein.
Und dann kannst du sagen, natürlich habe ich den Service versucht zu starten.
Der startet nicht.
Deswegen habe ich das Ticket auch bei euch aufgemacht.
Und dann kommt selten was raus.
Also Microsoft Support generell.
Generell, Support ist zum größten Teil komplett verschwendetes Geld.
Du musst dich entweder eh selbst drum kümmern oder dir was anderes suchen.
Es ist ganz selten in Fällen, dass es wirklich mal was gebracht hat.
Auch wenn du Oracle Support hast oder sowas.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als setzen die da irgendwie Entwickler hin und fixen für dich irgendeinen Bug oder so.
Wenn du Glück hast, haben die irgendeine interne Knowledge-Base, wo sie dir den Link zuschicken.
Wo du nur darauf zugreifen kannst, wenn du einen Account bei denen hast, wo steht, wie du das Feature irgendwie umbiegst.
Wo steht, wie du das Feature irgendwie umbiegst.
Wo denn dazu bezahlen kannst, so dass es doch funktioniert.
Also die meisten Support-Dinger sind wirklich relativ sinnlos.
Also die einzige Sache, wo es tatsächlich sinnvoll ist mit dem Support zu schreiben, bzw. wo es sich auch lohnt.
Ist Hardware.
Also wenn man irgendwelche Server gekauft hat von, wobei, das ist ja eher Lenovo oder HP oder Dell.
Und dort geht was kaputt und man braucht Ersatzteile.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber da machst du bei denen was auf oder sagst bei denen Beschalt und dann bekommst du ein neues Netzteil geschickt.
Das ist okay.
Bei IBM hast du früher die Fruen oder so.
Das ist dann einfach XJW scores Visa- gram.
Da hast du das richtig zutun.
Das machste bei denen.
gebraucht falls das noch irgendjemand kennt zwar auch immer so ein ding die hat jedes jedes teil
was austauschbar war bei ibm die hatten die hatten so ein aufkleber drauf mit einer mit einer fru
nummer das problem war nur die fru nummer war meistens an irgendwelchen stellen ja zum beispiel
irgendwo auf dem ramm oder sowas die war meistens auf irgendwelchen stellen wo du halt ohne das
system aufzumachen oder zumindest rauszuziehen auszuschalten nicht wirklich was gesehen hast
bis auf die ganz offensichtlichen und das konntest du ja nicht machen weil meistens die systeme ja
nicht kaputt waren sondern halt ein netzteil von zwei oder so ein gutes netzteil konnte raus
aber ich verstehe was ich meine und dann musst du immer ewig diskutieren mit dem ibm support
die bezahlen reaktionszeiten das ist ja das problem das ist aber vielen support so dass
du reaktionszeiten bezahlt und nicht wirklich sinnvolle lösungen
deswegen tut sich da auch meistens nix die reagieren dann auf die anfrage und sagen ja
wir haben unsere slas erfüllt und tschüss stimmt ich bin so froh dass ich mit microsoft
zeug nichts zu tun habe ganz im ernst ich habe letztens eine bewerbung gesehen von einem
bewerbungskandidat bei uns das war die krasseste bewerbung die ich je gesehen habe das waren sieben
seiten oh leck der stream was ist hier los vodafone please oh hier
was ist da los das war der krasseste lebenslauf beziehungsweise die krasseste skill liste aller
zeiten das waren sieben seiten und da war alles drauf leute ihr könnt es war wirklich alles drauf
da war sachen drauf windows linux solaris und dann standen noch irgendwie die einzelnen
derivate drauf distributionen drauf debian centos red hat windows 2003 windows 2008 und
c++ ruby bash alles alles der hatte wirklich sieben seiten skills das war natürlich nicht von
ihm geschrieben das hat irgendein vermittlungstyp geschrieben der halt gedacht hat okay viel hilf
viel das kann der im leben nicht alles auf dem niveau dass man ihn dafür einkaufen würde es
ist so wie wenn ich cobol in mein lebenslauf schreiben würde ja ihr wisst ich habe cobol
erfahrung
ich habe cobol erfahrung was jetzt aber nicht heißt dass ich das unbedingt in
meinen lebenslauf schreiben würde aber ungefähr auf dem niveau wird sich einiges dann dort bewegen
total was da teilweise reinkommt wir champ geist war immer noch der gemeint hat seine
abschlussarbeit ist geheim da darf er nichts darüber erzählen ist diese woche noch irgendwas
spannendes passiert zeigt mal kurz irgendwas interessantes gewesen als körperthermostatik
übrigens das eine sache stört mich bei heise auch zunehmend dass der news ticker so versteckt ist
und um rauszukriegen ob eine news interessant ist muss man einfach nach denen nach den comments
gucken platz auf der fernbedienung überhaupt keine fernbedienung ich brauche keinen button
für irgendwelche sender schummeln beim schach aha wie kann man überhaupt bescheißen beim schach wie
kann man bescheißen bei
aber das ist online
ach das ist online oder ja online kann man natürlich bescheißen
aber bei offline turnieren stelle ich mir schwer vor zu bescheißen also dass man online bescheißen kann
ok
die langweilige news langweilig langweilig
glasfaser jetzt umsteigen
die lecken critical information ich habe bei mir gibt es keine glasfasern dann würde ich
ich würde ja auch umsteigen
offline was mit perlen
hat dem dann im publikum irgendeiner signale gegeben oder wie
ey ey ohne schein
hey ohne schein
Unsere Gesundheitskarte, das ist auch so
ein Abfuck, was sie nie richtig hinkriegen
werden. GitHub führt private
Profile ein.
Echt? Hab ich ja mitgekriegt.
Ja, warum nicht?
Dankeschön für den Sub. Alles in Gucci.
Okay, nix fun ist dabei.
Internetsperren
im Iran. Ich hab gelesen,
Dota 2 ist jetzt
gebannt im Iran.
Ja, Dota 2
banned
im Iran irgendwo.
Oder im Irak? Ja, was auch immer.
Irgendwo. Ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Dota gebannt.
Weiß nicht. Nicht Allah approved
oder so. Ich weiß eh nicht, warum man
Spiele bannt.
Aber gut.
Keine Ahnung. Bei manchen Regierungen
in manchen Ländern wundert man sich echt über nix mehr.
Das USB-Firm
hat schon wieder die...
Wirklich? Es wird mich nicht wundern.
Moment.
Zeig mal.
Hier.
Wo denn?
USB-Branding changed again.
Oh ne, ich guck mir doch jetzt keine
keine 2 Stunden an.
USB.
Okay.
Redesigned logos finally make sense.
Ist ein Timestamp?
Okay.
Zeig mal. Kein Timestamp im Video.
Oder hier unten.
Ah ja, hier unten.
USB.
Okay. Sekunde.
Zeig mal. Ich blick nicht mehr durch. Ich hab zu viele Tabs.
Okay, wait.
Das USB-Implementer-Forum
ändert die Brandung
wieder.
Ich möchte nur einen Schautout
an GD Felt
auf dem Forum geben.
Langzeit-Mitglied, erste Post.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du ein langzeit-Mitglied bist.
Erste Post auf dem Forum.
Im Jahr 2019.
Okay, also gehen wir ein bisschen durch
das, was bis jetzt geführt hat.
Im Jahr 2019...
Nicht ein langzeit-Mitglied.
... der USB-Implementer-Forum.
Der USB-Implementer-Forum hat die folgenden
Namen geändert.
Sie haben USB 3.0 genommen,
was ziemlich selbstverständlich war.
Das ist ziemlich einfach.
Du kennst es, es ist der erste.
Das muss man ja sagen. Bis USB 3.0 waren die Sachen
eigentlich halbwegs in Ordnung.
Beziehungsweise bis USB 3.1 waren die Sachen
eigentlich halbwegs in Ordnung noch.
... und es ist USB 3.0.
Du hattest deinen USB 1.0 und 1.1, okay?
Das war der langweilige.
Dann hattest du deinen USB 2.0, okay?
Das war der schnellste.
Dann hattest du deinen USB 3.0,
das war der schnellerste.
Okay?
Die hatten ja irgendwie...
Was hatten die bei USB?
Super Speed?
Ultra Speed?
Okay.
They renamed USB 3.0...
Which was good.
... to USB 3.1 Gen 1.
Ja, genau.
Die haben 3.1 retroaktiv umbenannt dann.
Nee, Schwachsinn.
Ah, ich blick nicht mehr durch.
They renamed USB...
Genau.
Als dann 3.1...
Genau, die haben dann das immer retroaktiv umbenannt,
dass die alten Versionen die Versionsnummer
von der neuen Version trugen und sowas.
3.1, which was...
I don't even remember.
Das echte 3.1.
Was war das?
10 Gigabit?
I don't remember what the differentiation is.
I don't remember anymore.
But that got renamed to USB 3.1 Gen 2.
Then later it was actually renamed to 3.2 Gen 2.
And then USB 3.2...
Ach so, das war Gen 2x2.
... got renamed to USB 3.2 Gen 2x2.
The group sought to make things easier for consumers by recommending to vendors that they label products not by their specification name, but by super speed USB followed by the max speed.
Which, in my opinion, pretty okay.
Not bad.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, for example...
Denn das Problem ist halt, dass USB viel mehr ist als einfach nur die Geschwindigkeit.
USB 3.2 Gen 2x2 would become super speed USB 20 Gigabit per second.
Okay, so now the USB-IF is recommending...
Oh, jetzt wird hier Highlight gemessaged im Chat.
Das scheint mir ein neues Feature zu sein.
Wurde gestern auch gefragt, ob ich meine Nachricht nicht hervorheben will für 6 Euro oder sowas.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, nein.
Aber das ist ja nur für Channel Points.
... USB 3.2 Gen 2x2 super speed USB 20 Gigabit per second is now USB 20 Gigabit per second.
I like it.
Ja, ist okay.
I didn't actually know the conclusion to this when we got into it.
You know what's really great about it?
The best thing about it is that that's what I've been doing for years.
Yeah.
Ach, das war's jetzt, oder wie?
No one says super speed USB.
Instead of trying to do any of this.
Like, you guys watch me, watch me.
I don't always do this.
Ich sag doch die ganze Zeit auch schon, die sollen es so machen.
Wie das beispielsweise bei Wi-Fi 5, Wi-Fi 6 gemacht wurde.
Gut, warum wir jetzt Wi-Fi 6e brauchen?
Gut.
Ah ja, okay.
Das macht doch tatsächlich mal ein bisschen mehr Sinn.
So.
Ich will noch ein bisschen Tee trinken.
So, das ist ja Bescheid, dass die USB-Benahmung angeblich besser wird.
Mal gucken, ob das auch der Fall ist.
Oder ob die nächstes Jahr...
...diesen Kram dann wieder umbenennen in 2023 Gen 2.1 5x3.
Ja, das wollen sie jetzt hier anscheinend machen.
Das wollen sie jetzt hier anscheinend machen.
Allerdings intern heißt der Krempel immer noch so.
Aber wohl auf den Logos.
Ach, was weiß ich, was die da treiben.
Da blickt wirklich keiner mehr durch.
Ja, HDMI blickt auch keiner mehr durch.
Das ist richtig.
Das habe ich aber auch aufgegeben bei HDMI mittlerweile komplett.
Zum Glück muss man sich mit HDMI nicht so oft auseinandersetzen.
Warst du schon mal auf einer Expertenkonferenz?
Nö.
Nicht, dass ich mich...
Nichts, was ich als Expertenkonferenz klassifizieren würde.
Wo gehst du denn hin?
EMCC von ISIS.
Von denen habe ich schon mal was gehört.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Auf sowas war ich noch nicht.
Ich mag Konferenzen eh nicht sonderlich.
Und Messen auch nicht.
Ja, ich hoffe...
Ich hoffe, dein Chef bezahlt's.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Allerdings gerade im Entertainment-Bereich ist HDMI halt immer noch angesagt.
Also was Fernsehanschließen und sowas angeht, das ist halt HDMI und das wird wahrscheinlich auch erstmal HDMI bleiben.
Oder wie ist das, Leute?
Ich habe noch keinen Fernseher gesehen und irgendwelche Media-Player, die Display-Port verwenden.
Ich will gar nicht ausschließen, dass mein Fernseher nicht sogar theoretisch einen Display-Port hätte.
Ich glaube, der könnte sogar einen Display-Port haben.
Aber normalerweise wird das nicht...
Also mein Player hat...
Also das Android-TV hat keinen Display-Port.
Ja, ein bisschen, aber nicht wirklich groß zu merken.
Es haben ja seit Jahren, wenn nicht sogar schon seit 10 Jahren oder so mittlerweile, die gängigen CPUs, Crypto-Extensions für die Standard-Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmen.
Also das merkst du nicht.
Ich habe auch alle meine SSDs verschlüsselt und alle meine HDDs verschlüsselt.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, SSD, habe ich irgendeinen SSD-Benchmark?
Hätte ich euch mal zeigen können.
Das macht keinen Unterschied.
Das ist fast nicht messbar, der Unterschied.
Wieso eigentlich, wieso eigentlich was?
Warum ich nicht gerne auf Konferenzen oder irgendwelche Messen gehe oder so, sind mir einfach zu viele Leute.
Zu viele Leute, zu viele Leute, die mich überhaupt nicht interessieren und meistens halt auch zu wenig auf der Messe selbst, was mich interessiert.
Gerade Gamescom ist da ein gutes Beispiel für.
Die kannst du halt eigentlich komplett vergessen.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum Leute auf die Gamescom fahren.
Ich meine, wir hatten ja noch ein bisschen Glück.
Wir hatten diese, diese Area, wo man sich ein bisschen hinsetzen kann.
Wir haben im Vorfeld Termine gemacht, sodass man eben nicht 3 Stunden anstehen muss.
Das ging ja noch halbwegs und ich fand es schon so, schon kacke.
Aber wenn man da einfach nur hingeht und sich 3 Stunden an den Stand, keine Ahnung, ich verstehe nicht, warum man da hingeht.
Richtig.
Das ist das, das ist das, was so ein Storage-Treiber macht.
Also unter der Haube ist das auf der Disc, also hier, guckt mal.
Also die Platten, die sehen jetzt zwar unverschlüsselt aus, sind aber verschlüsselt.
Die sind nur entschlüsselt quasi im laufenden Betrieb.
Im laufenden Betrieb sind die Keys geladen, sodass man sie ver- und entschlüsseln kann.
Sobald ich den Rechner ausschalte, sind die Dinger verschlüsselt.
Und dann machst du da nichts.
Ja gut, wenn es eine Embedded-Conference ist, dass dann Experten über Embedded-Software sprechen, klingt das erstmal nachvollziehbar.
Ist das parallelisierbar?
Muss dich nicht interessieren.
Du verwendest die Crypto-Extensions deiner CPU.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die, dass es davon mehrere gibt und die parallel Sachen verarbeiten können.
Aber jede halbwegs aktuelle Software verwendet die CPU-Crypto-Extensions.
Also bei Intel heißen die Dinger zum Beispiel so.
Und mach mal einen Benchmark bei dir. Du wirst quasi sehen, wie viel da pro Sekunde durchgeht.
Das ist eigentlich keine Verschlechterung ohne Verschlüsselung zu verwenden.
Kann Veracrypt Lux öffnen? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Und das Filesystem, was dann drauf ist, höchstwahrscheinlich kann Windows nichts mit anfangen, weil da ist ja wahrscheinlich dann Ext4 oder XFS oder sowas drunter.
Aber obendrauf, obendrauf, nicht drunter, obendrauf.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob Veracrypt Lux öffnen kann, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ne.
Benutz ich nicht.
Benutz das da.
Nicht BitLocker.
Keck. BitLocker hat mich abgeschreckt.
Direkt von Anfang an, als Microsoft mal veröffentlicht hat, man könnte über irgendwelche Wege, ähm, wenn man ein Passwort verloren hat, könnte man irgendwie sein Passwort restoren lassen.
Kam ganz am Anfang mal als News raus.
Da brauchst du kein Tutorial, du klickst einfach den Assistent durch und dann ist dein System verschlüsselt.
Ähm.
Ganz am Anfang gab es eine News über, ich weiß gar nicht, ob da wirklich, ob das so schlimm ist, wie es sich angehört hat, ja, aber das hat mich komplett abgeschreckt von BitLocker.
Das erste, eines der ersten News, die ich von BitLocker gehört habe, ist, dass du irgendwie dein Passwort restoren lassen kannst über, über, über dein Microsoft Account oder sowas.
Und als ich gehört habe, die bieten eine Festplattenverschlüsselung an, bei der man das Passwort restoren kann, habe ich gewusst, okay.
Das ist scheiße.
Jegliche Verschlüsselung, wo irgendjemand anderes dein Passwort restoren kann, beziehungsweise dein Key restoren kann, ist scheiße.
Ordentlich verschlüsselt heißt, Passwort weg, alles verloren.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, was da genau dran ist.
Zumindest habe ich das so aus den News damals rausgelesen, reininterpretiert und seitdem habe ich nie wieder auch nur dran gedacht, BitLocker zu verwenden.
Gibt's bestimmt.
Ich stelle mir mal vor, irgendein Geschäfts-, irgendein Business-Notebook ist BitLocker verschlüsselt und hat dort wichtige Sachen drauf und vergisst sein Passwort.
Das kann man bestimmt so einstellen, dass die Firma das wieder entschlüsseln kann und sowas.
Kannst du, kannst du bestimmt irgendeinen Backup-Key im AD speichern und das kann dann nur der Admin wiederherstellen und das ist alles Müll.
Ganz ehrlich, alle Verschlüsselung, die du wiederherstellen kannst, außer mit dem Originalpasswort, ist Crap.
Wie gesagt, für Veracrypt brauchst du kein Tutorial.
Du machst das auf, wählst aus, was du haben willst, entweder Vollverschlüsselung von der Systemplatte oder eben Verschlüsselung erst nach dem Boot bzw. Einhängen erst nach dem Boot und nach dem Windows-Start einhängen und das war's.
Mehr musst du nicht machen.
Ich kann euch empfehlen, bei Veracrypt Key-Files zu verwenden und nicht Passwörter oder halt Passwörter mit Key-File, aber am besten ist, am besten ist die Festplatte.
Also ich mache es so, ich habe meine Festplatte verschlüsselt mit, also Vollverschlüsselung und die anderen mache ich über Key-File, die einmalig entsperrt werden müssen.
Weil ansonsten müsste ich dann irgendwie für drei Platten immer Passwörter eintippen oder für vier Platten Passwörter eintippen, das wäre mir zu doof.
Okay, Dual-Boot weiß ich nicht, das könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es damit Probleme hat.
Dual-Boot habe ich noch nie ausprobiert in der Kombi, da hätte ich aber auch meine Bedenken, ob das funktioniert, ja.
Dual-Boot ist irgendwas, das würde ich da in der Kombination wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
So, YouTube, du hast nochmal die Chance, uns was Sinnvolles zu empfehlen.
Nimmst du BitLocker? Ne.
Exposed, das Netzwerk der Klimaleugner.
Jetzt geht's schon wieder los hier.
Die gefährlichste Cyberwaffe, der übertreibt es immer so mit den Titeln, Alter.
Moin, Chat.
Zisch, nee, Zlschaib, was kann ich aussprechen, aber moin.
Major Changes, oh ja.
Massive Changes, diese Titel ist immer der gleiche G-Bait, ja.
Immer der gleiche G-Bait, die Leute glauben's.
Wir haben gestern die Major Changes gespielt, hat erstmal dazu geführt, dass die Lobby kaputt war.
Ich habe ein Jahr jedes Video in den Trends geguckt, die Videos sind meistens nicht schlecht.
Die Videos sind meistens gut.
Videotrends ist halt eh eklig.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, die Trends werden ja immer...
Unprominenter platziert, weil ganz im Ernst, ich wüsste gar nicht, wo die Trends überhaupt sind.
Hier, Explore, Trending, so.
Was trendet denn hier?
Clash of Clans.
So ein Schrott trendet.
Keckel, Alter.
Da ist nichts dabei, was ich gucken würde.
Helene Fischer.
Jawoll, endlich neuer Helene Fischer Song.
Ist ja noch schlimmer.
Da ist ja noch mein Key zum Entschlüsseln in der Cloud liegen.
Das ist ja genau das, was ich haben will.
Ich möchte unbedingt das Passwort, beziehungsweise den Key zum Entschlüsseln meiner Daten in der Cloud speichern.
Ganz wichtig.
Kann mir nichts besseres vorstellen.
Der View-Count in Trends gibt an, wie viele Gehirnzellen gestorben sind.
Ja, aber nur bei einer Person.
So.
Was schauen wir uns denn jetzt an?
Ne, mein eigenes Video.
Komm, wir gucken uns das an.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was dabei rumkommt.
Okay.
Wer ist aktuell die relevanteste Person auf YouTube?
Welche Themen werden am allermeisten angeklickt?
Wer ist die relevanteste Person auf YouTube?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt absolut nicht den leisesten, plastesten Schimmer.
Nicht den kleinsten Hauch einer Ahnung.
Also, früher hätte ich mal gesagt sowas wie PewDiePie, aber das ist es ja garantiert nicht mehr.
Ganz am Anfang von YouTube war der größte Abonnent, wie hieß der?
Ray?
Nee.
Irgendwas mit Johnson oder so?
Ray Johnson?
William Johnson?
Ray William Johnson?
Irgendwie so, oder?
Ray William Johnson.
Genau.
Den gab es, der war saukroß am Anfang.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es den überhaupt noch gibt.
Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Okay.
Oh, der macht jetzt nur noch Shorts, oder was?
Alter.
Das geht ja richtig ab.
Der hat mal jahrelang, hat sich, jahrelang war der richtig, war der, war der richtig
der, der hat der Channel.
WTF?
Mit Shorts hat er hier anscheinend sein, sein neues, neues Ding gefunden, Mann.
Krass.
Der, der Channel war mal voll im, voll im Arsch.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es den noch gibt.
Dick im, dick im Shorts-Game, ja.
Wahnsinn.
Und ansonsten, jetzt hätte ich wirklich absolut keine Ahnung, wer die wichtigste Person auf
YouTube oder die, die bekannteste oder so Person auf YouTube ist.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung.
Nicht mal, ich könnte es noch nicht mal für Deutschland sagen.
... ist zum Beispiel Funk im Verhältnis zu klassischen Medienhäusern eine Möglichkeit,
wie man all das und noch viel mehr feststellen kann.
Der Unterschied ist, Funk kostet mich Geld.
... wäre ein Jahr lang zu untersuchen, was jeden Tag die angesagtesten Videos auf YouTube
sind.
Ja, auf geht's.
Das Ding ist nur, in den YouTube-Trends sind immer 50 Videos gleichzeitig.
Das heißt, wenn man...
Ja, okay, aber man müsste sich das theoretisch wahrscheinlich auch angucken, die Trends.
Sind die Trends immer gleich oder sind die Trends schon personalisiert?
Also sprich, müsste ich das immer mit einem anonymen Tab aufmachen?
... das ein Jahr lang machen würde, wären das 18.250 Videos, die man untersuchen müsste...
Ja.
... um herauszufinden, wer am meisten so getrendet ist.
Auf geht's.
Und wer wäre dumm genug, sich das anzutun?
Ich auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich habe dafür nämlich Praktikanten.
Kapitel 1, die Daten.
Wir, ich sage einfach mal wir, mein Team und ich, wir haben jeden Abend zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
in mühsamer Handarbeit ein Jahr lang eingetragen, welche YouTube-Videos gerade in den YouTube-Trends
waren.
Und jetzt denken vielleicht ein paar von euch, hä, hätte man das nicht auch einfach mit
einer Software automatisieren können?
Ja, die Idee ist mir dann auch nach ein paar Monaten gekommen, weil wir dann so ein paar
Lücken in den Daten hatten, weil die Praktikanten auch mal Urlaub wollten.
Und dann hat Rezo mir netterweise mit Nindo was gebaut, mit dem wir dann die Lücke in
den Daten stopfen konnten.
Größte Liebe deswegen an Rezo und an Nindo.
Shoutout geht raus, falls ihr irgendwie im Marketing-Bereich arbeitet und Nindo Pro noch
nicht ausgecheckt habt, macht das.
Kommt jetzt Werbung.
Allein nur deswegen, weil Rezo hat dieses Video gerettet.
Und dank fleißigen Praktikanten...
Da hätte er sich mal zumindest die Haare blau färben können, oder?
... Praktikantinnen und dank Nindo haben wir also die laut YouTube rund um den Tag
rund 18.000 relevantesten Videos zwischen dem 1. Februar 2021...
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, das könnte man ja sogar relativ easy ohne irgendwelche Analyse-Tools
machen.
Ich meine, das könntest du wirklich auf die absolut simpelste Art und Weise überhaupt
Du weghettest dir einfach einmal abends die Trend-Seite und Webscrapes dir dann irgendwas
aus dem HTML raus.
Also das ist tatsächlich sogar easy.
Da musst du weder YouTube-API noch sonstige Geschichten machen.
Also die einfache Auswertung davon dürfte wahrscheinlich...
Und wenn YouTube sagt, weghett geht nicht, dann nimmst du irgendeinen Chrome ferngesteuert.
... 30. Januar 2022 auswerten können.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt wieder fragt, hä?
Warum kommt das Video dann im September?
Habt ihr schon mal versucht 18.000...
Die erfolgreichsten YouTube-Kanäle laut den Trends.
Okay, auf geht's.
Das Erste, was ich aus den Daten rauslesen konnte, ist...
Du hast überhaupt nicht jedes Video in den Trends geguckt.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt tatsächlich nur ein paar hundert Kanäle, die es regelmäßiger in die Trends
schaffen.
Für dieses Video habe ich jetzt mal die Top 50 rausgesucht.
Und tut mir jetzt am Anfang...
Gibt es eigentlich HairTutorial noch?
Aus irgendwelchen...
Weiß nicht...
Der war ja auch angesagt 2010 rum.
Gibt es?
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
HairTutorial YouTube.
Tatsächlich, den gibt es immer noch.
Aber nur noch sehr unregelmäßig.
Aber nur noch sehr unregelmäßig, hä?
Ach, sind sie jetzt alle aus Dubai wieder da, oder wie?
War das mit Steuern sparen in Dubai doch nicht so geil bei den ganzen...
Das war ja mal eine Zeit lang irgendwie der Trend, dass alle YouTuber nach Dubai gegangen
sind.
Überlegt mal einmal kurz für euch, wen seht ihr auf Platz 1?
Was wäre so euer erster Instinkt für den relevantesten, trendigsten YouTube-Kanal des
letzten Jahres?
MrBeast?
In...
Also, nee, nicht in Deutschland.
International vielleicht?
In Deutschland?
Gut, MontanaBlack ist jetzt auf YouTube nicht mehr so.
Das ist ja alles eher Twitch.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe wirklich keinen Plan, wer da in Deutschland angesagt ist.
Mal gucken.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Platz 50.
Das war MrWissen2go.
Der war 33 Tage lang in den Trends im letzten Jahr.
Ja, schlecht.
Leeroywillswissen und SteuerungF hatten jeweils einen Tag mehr.
Bei Felaude waren es dann 35.
Und unter den Trends, die wir jetzt sehen, haben wir einen Tag mehr.
Und unter den Trendigsten YouTube-Kanälen, da waren auch ein paar Unternehmen wie das
Miniatur Wunderland.
Was?
Du...
Ach, wieder...
Besonders spannend fand ich aber Marvin.
Der war auch 35 Tage in den Trends.
Hey, das ist der erste Channel, von dem ich ab und zu schon mal was geguckt habe.
...in den Trends.
Natürlich insbesondere wegen HydroHype aus dem letzten Jahr.
Ja, stimmt.
Der war das.
Ja.
Der hat in dem gesamten Zeitraum aber nur 20 Videos hochgeladen.
Und das liegt daran, dass nicht jedes Video immer 24 Stunden lang trendet.
Manche trenden auch nur eine ganz kurze Zeit, manche aber eben auch für mehrere Tage.
Und von dem...
Ich hab noch nie was von Miniatur Wunderland gehört.
...20 Videos, die Marvin im letzten Jahr hochgeladen hat, sind nur fünf nicht in unseren Daten
aufgetaucht.
Marvin ist also wirklich einer der relevantesten YouTuber des letzten Jahres gewesen.
Und jedes Mal, wenn er was hochgeladen hat, ist es quasi in den Trends gelandet.
Es folgten dann Jinder Uwes, Couple on Tour, noch nie gehört, Shirin David, die auch nur
15 Videos hochgeladen hat und damit 36 Tage in den Trends war, Freshtorge, Coldmirror,
Vinny Piano, Coldmirror gibt's auch noch, jemand, wo ich schon mal gehört hab was von,
Vizcar Bazaar, Simplicissimus und Paluten.
Moment, Moment, Vizcar Bazaar, den kenn ich auch noch aus Call of Duty-Zeiten, Simplicissimus
und Paluten.
Wusste ich gar nicht, wusste ich gar nicht, dass der, dass der auch noch abgeladen hat.
Und dann, und das hätte ich nicht erwartet, die NFL und dann MyLab, die nur 11 Videos
hochgeladen hat in unserem Zeitraum und damit 37 Tage in den Trends war und zwar jedes der
11 Videos war in den Trends.
Und damit ist MyLab tatsächlich der Kanal, der laut meinen Daten prozentual zum Upload-Pensum
mit Abstand am meisten getrendet ist.
Julien Berg hat das mit seinem Hauptkanal zwar auch geschafft, die haben drei Hauptvideos
hochgeladen und alle drei waren jeweils drei Tage in den Trends, aber basierend auf der
höheren Anzahl an Uploads, könnte man sagen, dass MyLab die relevanteste YouTuberin im
letzten Jahr war.
Es gibt aber eben auch eine ganze Menge andere Kanäle, die weitaus mehr Zeit in den Trends
verbracht haben und um die geht es jetzt gleich und auch darum, wie vor bis jetzt abgeschnitten
hat.
Kommt der Sponsor erst mal.
Ich wusste es, jetzt kommt erst mal der Sponsor.
Ich, ich kenne Überleitung mittlerweile.
Bevor wir dazu kommen, muss ich einmal gucken.
Wir suchen weiter nach dem relevantesten YouTube-Kanal Deutschlands laut den YouTube-Trends und ich
für immer noch, keiner von euch wird es erraten.
Nach MyLab kommt jetzt erst mal Sportstudio Fußball, Capital Bra, Varyon, Joko und Klaas,
Der Spiegel, Köln 5066.
Alter, ich gucke nichts davon.
Und dann ein Kanal von DAZN.
Und da wird es richtig spannend, denn eine Sache, die ich festgestellt habe, ist, nichts
ist mehr in den deutschen Trends als Fußball-Kanäle.
Ja, das wundert mich in Deutschland jetzt wirklich nicht.
DAZN taucht nämlich noch vier weitere Male in den Top 50 auf mit fünf unterschiedlichen
Kanälen.
In Deutschland ist DAZN über all ihre Kanäle hinweg 425 Mal in den Trends gewesen.
Dass Fußball in Deutschland in den Trends ist, das wundert mich nicht.
Das ist mehr als der DSB öffentlich-rechtliche Kanäle wie Sportstudio und Sportschau und
auch alle Sportkanäle von Sky zusammen.
DAZN ist tatsächlich nach meiner Einschätzung die relevanteste Medienmarke auf YouTube gewesen,
wenn man die Trends als Grundlage nimmt.
Die einzige Frage ist, kann Funk das toppen?
Und es gibt natürlich noch einzelne.
In den Top 50 folgen noch Clash of Clans, Bullion Jam, Maxify, Internationale Kanäle
sind auch dabei.
Maxify?
Nicht der mit dem ähm mit diesem Dinosaurier Schlafanzug?
Brawl Stars, MrBeast, Survival Magic, Team Harrison, das Musiklabel Life is Pain TV, Trimax,
der deutsche Kanal von Kurzgesagt und Sam.
Ja ok.
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist eines der wenigen Channels die hier drin sind die ich ab und
zu mal gucke.
Und jetzt sind wir schon bei.
Ich kenne die meisten.
Chat wie gehts euch?
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich kenne 90% der Channels nicht.
In den Top 10 und eine Sache möchte ich da dazu sagen, von den Top 10 gehören nur 5 Plätze
klassischen YouTube Creatern, allerdings gehört uns der Top Platz.
Davor kommen aber noch LaserLuka, JuliaBeautix, BibisBeautyPalace und Fritz Meinecke.
Der hat im letzten Jahr Seven vs.
Wild rausgebracht.
Das war das Format des Jahres.
Und das sieht man hier und das sieht man auch in den Trends, wenn man alle Reacts und Videos
die rund um Seven vs.
Wild entstanden sind mitzählt, dann waren tatsächlich 92 Tage Seven vs.
Wild Inhalte in den Trends.
Nicht schlecht.
Und jetzt bleiben natürlich nur noch die Top 2 Plätze und ich muss sagen, beide haben
mich mega überrascht.
123 Tage lang in den Trends, mehr als jeden dritten Tag, war Berlin Tag und Nacht.
Berlin Tag und Nacht.
Seriously.
Dieser Schrott, Alter.
Ist so viel in den Trends, dass als wir auswerten wollten, welche Themen und Wortkombinationen
in Video-Titel am meisten trenden, Berlin Tag und Tag und Nacht mehr vorgekommen sind
in der Analyse, als ich habe, als ich habe und Official Trailer.
Mehr als FIFA 22.
Nur Official Video produced by Music Video und Champions League kommen noch mehr vor und
wenn man sich drei Wortkombinationen anguckt, sind es Official Music Video und Champions
League.
Und wenn die Laptops unter eine Auszeichnung dann noch mal stehen.
Musikvideo, Berlin Tag und Nacht, Seven Riders, Clash of Clans ist auch so hoch, das ist wild
und UEFA Champions League. Aber wer war denn jetzt der YouTube-Kanal, der am meisten in
den Trends war? Es ist JP Performance. Hättet ihr das gedacht? JP Performance ist der YouTube-Kanal
über alle Kanäle hinweg, wenigstens kenne ich den ersten Platz, der am meisten in den
Trends war, 128 Tage lang. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann es mir nicht erklären, Fritz Meinecke,
Marvin, MyLab, Fußball, selbst Berlin Tag und Nacht, die hätte ich irgendwie kommen
sehen, aber JP Performance doppelt so oft wie der nächste klassische YouTuber unter
ihm. Und um unter den Top 100 trendigsten Kanälen zu sein, muss man im Jahr nur 20 Tage
in den Trends gewesen sein. JP Performance war 108 Tage lang mehr in den Trends. Die
haben doch in seiner Firma irgendeinen Trick rausgebracht.
Ich habe den Trick nicht, aber eine Sache, die ich festgestellt habe, ist, Kanäle mit
weniger Uploads trenden mehr. Marvin, Julien Bam, MyLab oder auch mein Kanal. Ich war neun
Tage in den Trends mit sechs von meinen acht Uploads, die ich im letzten Jahr hatte. Abonniert
meinen Kanal. Wie kommt man eigentlich in die Trends? Möglichst viele Views in einem Tag
oder muss das irgendein YouTube-Typ Hand rauspicken?
Ich lade nur acht Mal hoch. Das Abo lohnt sich.
Kapitel 3. Wie schneidet Funk ab? Wie oft warst du in den Trends? Wahrscheinlich null
mal.
Tatsächlich hat mich ein anderer YouTuber zu diesem Experiment inspiriert. Coffee Break,
der hat vor dreieinhalb Jahren schon mal eine ähnliche Trendsanalyse in den USA gemacht.
Bei ihm ging es viel darum, wie viel Trends wird in den USA von Late-Night-Shows und amerikanischen
Fernsehsendern beherrscht. Für Deutschland fand ich deswegen eine spannende Frage, wie
trendy ist Funk eigentlich?
In den Top 50 Kanälen?
Ja.
In den Top 50 Kanälen haben wir ja schon acht Projekte von Funk gesehen. Und insgesamt,
laut meinen Daten, war Funk letztes Jahr 548 Mal in den Trends. Also mehr, weitaus mehr
als DAZN noch. Allerdings natürlich auch mit mehr einzelnen Kanälen. Das hier, das
sind die 35 Funk-Projekte, die ich in den Trends finden konnte. Funk ist auf jeden Fall
die mit Abstand größte einzelne Quelle für extra für YouTube produzierten Content, der
dann in den Trends landet.
Alle Videos hinweg wollte ich mir auch nochmal die Verteilung angucken. Klassische YouTube
Kanäle haben rund 45% aller Trends ausgemacht. Werbung von Unternehmen waren so bei 3%, Filme
und Spieltrailer bei 4%, Musik bei 14% und Produktionen von größeren Medienhäusern
bei 25%. Zwischenzeitlich waren auch noch 7% Shorts, die waren zeitweise in den Trends,
jetzt haben die ihre eigenen Trends. Das waren dann meistens virale Hits von random Leuten.
Sehr spannend fand ich aber auch noch, dass Gronkh und O-Ton, die sich in den Trends befinden,
sich in den Trends befinden, sich in den Trends befinden, sich in den Trends befinden, sich in den Trends
befinden, sich in den Trends befinden, sich aufgetaucht haben und sich in den Trends
befinden, sich in den Trends befinden, sich in den Trends befinden.
Ich habe auch ausprobiert, dass Gronkh und Unge die größten Kanäle nach Abos waren,
die verhältnismäßig am wenigsten in den Trends waren für ihre Abos. Gronkh war ein
einziges Mal in den Trends.
Ja gut, das kann ich insofern nachvollziehen. Let's Plays ist jetzt ja was. Da sticht jetzt
kein einziges, also kein einzelnes Video in der Form raus, dass das dann übelst abgeht.
Gronkh spielt nur neun Tage, genauso viel wie ich. Das hat aber glaube ich einen Grund,
die neunmal dir in den Trends waren. Das waren alles Videos, die alle super wichtig
waren aus seinem Leben.
Junge, taucht aber der Rest des irgendwelches Reaction-Zeug tatsächlich mit seinen Reacts ganz oft in den Gaming-Trends auf.
Das sind separate Trends aus irgendeinem Grund und die haben wir nicht extra ausgewertet und wahrscheinlich war da noch eine Menge los.
Da waren wahrscheinlich auch Leute wie Knossi oder MontanaBlack und deswegen sind die hier nicht, obwohl die eigentlich ziemlich relevant sind.
Falls ihr sonst noch Fragen oder auch Ideen habt, was wir noch mit den Daten machen können, wenn ihr Fragen habt, hey, ist dieser YouTuber in den Trends gewesen und wie oft, schreibt mir das.
Ähm, ich muss sagen, wie gesagt, 90% der Kanäle haben mir überhaupt nichts gesagt, aber ich ignoriere zum größten Teil eh.
Also YouTube Deutschland ignoriere ich zum allergrößten Teil und auch Mainstream YouTube International geht mir sonst wo vorbei.
Ja, weniger Pfeifert, viel, viel weniger Pfeifert.
Wenn David Kriesel das ausgewertet hätte, der hätte dir gesagt, welche YouTuber mit welchem YouTuber fremdgehen aktuell anhand der Video-Upload-Zeiten und Daten.
Kann ich mich trauen.
Das anzuklicken.
Der langsame Tod der Trends.
Ich wette, niemand...
Können wir gleich gucken.
Moment, das ist falsch.
Das hier ist ja gar nicht mein.
Das ist ja, ich hab zu viele Tabs, Leute.
Ich wette...
Zu viele Tabs.
Blink ich da mal durch.
Don't commit secrets, das ist korrekt.
Leute, es ist letzte Woche wieder was passiert, das hab ich nicht für möglich gehalten.
Ich hab's auch, ich hab's ja schon auf Twitter gepostet.
Nein, nicht mein neuer Kubernetes-Cluster.
Das da.
Warum fragen mich Leute, die Senior-Admin sind, wo ihr SSH-Verzeichnis ist?
Da frage ich mich immer, wann wirst du zum Senior-Admin bei uns?
Musst du einfach nur lang genug dabei sein?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, zu seiner Ehrenrettung muss man sagen, es ist Windows.
Aber es geht nicht darum, wo es unter Windows liegt, sondern wo es in WSL liegt.
Und ganz im Ernst.
Einem Senior-Admin traue ich das durchaus zu, das auch in WSL zu finden.
Und selbst wer das nicht findet, einfach mal in Google einzugeben, SSH-Directory Linux.
Und dann findet er es auch.
Es ist ja nicht, als wäre das supergeil versteckt gewesen.
Also, ich verstehe es teilweise nicht.
Alter, die Leute bei uns, die haben teilweise richtige Profis am Werk.
Ich frag mich dann immer, wenn du mit sowas Senior-Admin wärst.
Wenn du Senior-Admin werden kannst.
Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Bin ich dann Ur-Opa-Admin oder wie?
Ist aber nicht nur bei euch so.
Ja, ich weiß.
Es ist normal, dass 90% der Leute keine Ahnung haben von ihrem Job.
Ur-Opa-Admin.
Der Kerl war noch älter als ich.
Oh Mann.
Wahnsinn.
Also, Sachen, die hält man nicht für möglich.
8 Free Websites, you probably done.
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Stadia.
Keck.
Alles rund um Cloud Gaming.
Oh, dieser Channel hat, glaube ich, gerade Probleme.
Das können wir uns sonst noch angucken hier.
Why most Google employees quit after 1.1 years?
Und das ist ein Wort, das macht mir immer was.
Das macht mir immer zu schaffen.
Ich kann mir nicht merken, ob es Average oder Average heißt.
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar, je nachdem.
Wen du fragst, wird es alles.
Es ist so wie Garage.
Manche sagen Garage, manche sagen Garage und wir.
Aber das Schlimmste ist immer noch, was Englisch angeht, dass die ihr WW aussprechen.
Das werde ich nie lernen.
Ich musste letzte Woche übrigens mit einem rein englischsprachigen Telekom-Techniker wieder Server fixen bei uns.
Das ist immer lustig.
Weil das ist kein Native Speaker und ich bin auch kein Native Speaker, aber irgendwie funktioniert es trotzdem.
Was ich noch nicht probiert habe, ein paar Twitch-E-Mails einzubauen, um zu checken, ob er sich da auskennt.
Also von seinem Namen her würde ich sagen, er kommt aus Tschechien oder so.
Und ich höre es auch so ein bisschen am Akzent.
Akzent?
Und bei mir hörst du halt ganz klar, dass ich German bin.
Ja, da sind sie nicht die einzigen.
The Germans, genau.
So, was kommt?
Why most Google employees quit after one?
Okay.
Lass mich raten.
Okay, ich predikte mal, warum die meisten Google-Mitarbeiter nach einem Jahr aufhören.
Oder nach etwas über einem Jahr.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es nach einem Jahr einen Bonus.
Und den wollen doch alle irgendwie mitnehmen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es einfach...
...einfach deutlich stressiger ist, als man sich das Ganze vorgestellt hat.
Und...
...dass dieses Ganze, wir haben uns so lieb und spielen den ganzen Tag Konsole im Büro und chillen auf der Terrasse, nicht der Realität entspricht.
Und in Wirklichkeit kaum einer diese Dinger wirklich verwendet, weil sie dann quasi schepp angeguckt werden, wenn sie es verwenden.
Das ist ein bisschen so...
...also so eine Sache, die ich selbst erlebt habe.
Dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe und wo ich danach beim Internet oder beim Provider gearbeitet habe, die hatten auch eine Bar oben im Dachgeschoss.
Die hatten so die typischen Tischkicker-Geschichten, irgendeinen Entspannungsraum.
Und wisst ihr, wie oft das Zeug verwendet wurde?
Nahezu nie.
Warum wurde das nicht verwendet?
Naja, weil dich alle schepp angeguckt haben, wie du gehst in den Entspannungsraum, anstatt weiterzuarbeiten.
Ja, und das war reines, reines, wir können es im Bewerbungszeug gut verkaufen, dass es sowas gibt.
Die hatten aber auch andere komische Sachen.
Also ich bin froh, dass ich da weg bin.
Also, die hatten auch andere Sachen.
Die hatten sowas wie Freitagabends wurde dann immer noch irgendwie was getrunken oben zusammen.
Und ihr wisst, wie viel Bock ich auf irgendwelche sozialen Events mit random Leuten habe.
Und ich war ja selten da.
Ja, glücklicherweise, dass ich da hin...
Aber du wurdest da auch schepp angeguckt, wenn du gesagt hast, ich gehe jetzt einfach heim.
So nach dem Motto, ja wie, du willst 19 Uhr nicht noch mit deinen Kollegen am Freitag was trinken?
Nee.
Und 19 Uhr schon mal gar nicht.
16 Uhr, wenn es hochkommt.
Also ganz im Ernst.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es in Google...
Dass es in Google auch...
Kack, bye.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es in Google ähnlich...
Ehrlich, es ist bloß noch schlimmer.
So, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Google Employees and Relationships that start on Tinder...
Der hat aber sein Bass ganz schön hochgedreht.
...have one thing in common.
On average, they don't last very long.
While employees in America stay with a company for 4.1 years on average,
a typical Googler quits in just 1.1 years.
So, why does the number one, best place to work for many years in a row,
famous for benefits and perks, massages, mouthwatering meals,
where 3 million people apply to work every year?
With all this...
Why does Google have such a massive problem keeping people around?
Wie gesagt, unterm Strich, unterm Strich, ich gehe davon aus, es ist einfach zu stressig.
Google is hiding some dark secrets or why maybe the reason people move on so fast
is they rocket onto something even greater success, fame and fortune after just one year.
Ist das Asmongold gewesen gerade?
Was zum...
...after just one year?
Nee, nee, aber es sah gerade aus dem Augenwinkel echt so aus.
... after just one year.
This video is purely based on the reasons that ex-Google employees gave for quitting.
From seeking more freedom to extreme frustration with the work environment to creating their own start-ups.
Ah, die Musik wieder.
Ja, okay, wir haben jetzt genug aufregende Musik gehabt.
Here are five major reasons why most Googlers say goodbye to Google in one year or less.
Ja, auf, erzähl.
The Perk Trap.
Recently, a controversial TikTok video shows the dark side of Google's exclusive perks.
Now you might wonder, what could go wrong with receiving benefits at work?
Because at first, nothing seems shady.
Employees work hard contributing to the company so they get rewarded with benefits.
But what if the benefits have a dark side and are nothing but bait to keep you trapped?
This is what Ken Walks, a former employee, said in a controversial TikTok that went viral this year.
Aspiring young workers flock to the company assuming they have amazing work-life balance.
They have amazing work-life balance, eat delicious food and play ping pong with colleagues.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Also wer das wirklich glaubt, dem ist, okay, gut.
Das sind meistens Leute, die kommen direkt von der Uni, die hatten wahrscheinlich noch keinen Kontakt mit der Realität.
Also wir haben uns doch schon total oft hier im Stream Videos angeguckt.
Diese Videos.
One day in the life of bla bla bla.
At Uber, at Google, at sonstwas.
Und man kann doch sofort erkennen, was realistisch ist.
Was realistisch ist und was nicht ist.
Diese Videos, die am Anfang sich erstmal einen Smoothie machen, dann erstmal irgendwie auf der Terrasse rumchillen,
dann erstmal eine Runde Ping-Pong spielen, zwischendurch mal eine halbe Stunde programmieren oder so.
Da ist uns doch allen klar und bewusst, das ist alles Fake.
Aber gut, wenn man das natürlich glaubt und mit der Erwartung hingeht, dann ist die Enttäuschung natürlich vorprogrammiert.
Das ist so, wie Google sich vorprogrammiert.
Was hat der da für einen Stuhl?
Google portrays itself.
But according to Ken, this may be careful marketing just to attract employees.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Und what you actually see is to get employees to stay for longer.
For example, Google serves three tasty meals a day,
but they don't serve dinner until between 6 and 6.30.
Ey, das ist eigentlich richtig clever von Google.
Moment, wann gibt's die?
Wann gibt's die Dinger?
Ja, gut.
clever von Google. Moment, wann
gibt's die? Wann gibt's die Dinger?
Ja gut, guck mal, du kriegst das 18 Uhr,
18 Uhr 30 kriegst du
Freedom Times, ja, also
es ist 18 Uhr und 18 Uhr 30.
18 Uhr 30 bin ich seit
ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden schon daheim.
18 Uhr 30, das heißt
im Endeffekt,
du bist bis
vorneweg 19 Uhr
beschäftigt. 19 Uhr auf der Arbeit,
bis 19 Uhr.
Und danach machen die wahrscheinlich noch irgendwelche komischen
anderen Entertainment-Dinger
oder so. Und die meisten Leute
schlafen dann wahrscheinlich auch im Büro.
Weil, warum sollte ich jetzt noch heimfahren?
Das heißt, die fahren dann
morgens mit hin und abends mit heim
und dann kommt nochmal eine Stunde,
zwei Stunden drauf.
Wahrscheinlich ist es dann sogar so, ey, das ist
doppelt gut für Google, gell?
Die Leute können dann quasi
diese Sinnlos-Tasks wie
E-Mails lesen oder
auf irgendwelche komischen Dinge antworten
und so, das können die im Bus machen
und dann haben die auf der Arbeit
wirklich Zeit,
10 Stunden
Five-Hat-Kram durchzuarbeiten.
Kein Wunder, das hältst du ja nicht aus.
Du hältst ja nicht aus, 10 Stunden
am Tag
hirnanstrengende Arbeit zu machen.
Kein Wunder, dass du das nicht länger
als ein Jahr aushältst.
Was?
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Alter, die Musik im Hintergrund.
Ich nicht.
Nein.
Warum?
Leute, was habe ich denn von einem
Abendessen auf der Arbeit,
wenn ich dafür zweieinhalb Stunden länger
da bleiben muss und ansonsten außer der Arbeit
kein anderes Leben mehr habe?
Also ist das ein kostenloses Abendessen?
Wirklich das, was das aufwiegt?
Nee, Abendessen musst du wahrscheinlich nicht bezahlen
Stress, ja
Alter, die Musik, Mann, ist ja gut, Alter
Reg dich ab
By the way, wie soll man eigentlich arbeiten in so einem Environment?
Wie soll, warte mal
Guckt euch das mal an, wie soll man da arbeiten?
Wie soll er bitte schön arbeiten?
Was geht denn da im Hintergrund bei dem Abendessen?
Ich meine, okay, das ist jetzt ja nicht Google
Und das ist von irgendeinem anderen Video
Aber, was ist das?
The fuck?
Ja, das glaube ich denen sofort
Leute, und wisst ihr, wisst ihr was?
Ich sage euch mal was, hier
53% sagen
Ja, unser Job ist extrem
Stressvoll
Und davon, also nicht von diesen 53%
Obendrauf kommen nochmal 40%
Die sich selbst nicht eingestehen wollen
Oder nicht zugeben wollen
Das sind viel mehr
Das sind die 53%, die es schon realisiert haben
Die anderen 40%
Haben es wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht eingesehen
Oder wollen sich nicht eingestehen
Stressvoll
No wonder ex-Google-Employees claim Google acts like a demanding girlfriend
Even with the unlimited vacation, work from home
Ja, unlimited
Unlimited vacation ist auch so ein Ding
Wer traut sich bitte schön
Unlimited vacation zu nehmen
Also irgendwie 8 Wochen im Jahr oder so
Wenn du dann immer noch schepp angeguckt wirst
Dieses unlimited, da gibt es sogar
Da gibt es doch sogar, da gab es von nicht allzu langer Zeit
Eine Untersuchung zu
Das unlimited vacation in der Regel dazu führt
Dass die Leute weniger
Urlaub nehmen
Als sonst
Also wenn einer 20 Jahre
Keine Ahnung, einer hat 25 Tage Urlaub
Dann nimmt er das
Und wenn du unlimited hast
Dann führt es eher dazu, dass die Leute weniger nehmen
Ja, ist so, die nehmen sich weniger Urlaub
Hey
So einen Ruheraum
Haben wir jetzt bei der Arbeit, wo ich bin
Plus dort, wo ich vorher beim Provider gearbeitet habe
Auch
Und diesen Ruheraum nimmt niemand in Anspruch
Die Frage ist
Sind diese Dinge tatsächlich
Unlimited vacation?
Also, wenn wir uns auf PayScales-Report ansehen
Und was Ex-Googlers sagen
Es scheint, dass es nicht so ist
Aber warum?
Weil viele Google-Anbieter
Bekamen, dass sie fühlten, als gäbe es eine Kultur
Von ihnen, die gegen den Klocken arbeiten
Und sie hatten keine Zeit, um sich zu entschärfen
Und sich nicht zu stressen
Weil es schwierig ist, Leisure-Zeit zu haben
Wenn du nur über die Aufgabe denkst, die du hinter dir bist
Wegen einer aggressiven
Und Ex-Googlers sagen, dass
Wegen dieser Abläufe
Sie immer hinter dem Schedule fühlten
Und nur in unheimlichen Fällen
Wenn die Mannschaft glücklich war
Aber sie tatsächlich ein Projekt auf Zeit beendet
Nun, in dieser Situation
Ist es sehr einfach, etwas zu rationalisieren
Wie das Skippen des Gym
Wenn dein ganzes Team auch arbeitet
Nun, es ist nicht so, als würde jemand dich stoppen
Aber du kannst als ein Slacker gesehen werden
Für nicht so hart arbeiten
Wie die restlichen Teams
Und wenn du als ein hart arbeitender
Du kannst diese leckeren Mahlzeiten
An deinem Tisch essen
Nun, du kannst einen Kommentar schreiben
Der sagt, hey, du hast deine Perks
Du hast den hohen Salar
Also stopp du von den Verbrechen
Aber wenn du tatsächlich in der Umgebung bist
Ist es ein bisschen anders
Nicht jeder kann das beantworten
Das ist ein bisschen anders
Du kannst auch fragen
Ist Coding selbst eine stressvolle Sache zu tun?
Während der heutige Sponsor das nicht denkt
Wenn du lernen und mit Coding erzielen willst
Während du gleichzeitig
Eine stressfreie Leben lebst
Schau dir das Freemo Code Bootcamp an
Wo du lernen wirst
Fronten-Coding und
Lokation-independente Jobhunting-Skillen
Du kannst nicht mit Google anfangen
Aber es gibt viele Unternehmen
Die sich für Remote-Developer suchen
Ist das jetzt Werbung?
Ist das jetzt einfach übergegangen in Werbung?
Viel mehr als genug
Um zu überleben und einen guten Einkommen zu machen
Du kannst eine gratis Konsultation
Das ist jetzt einfach Werbung
In der Umgebung
In der Beschreibung unten
Lass uns zurück in das Video
Und gehen auf die dritte Grund
Es ist schwierig zu überleben
Ich will nicht dramatisch sein
Aber wenn du mit Google arbeitest
Kannst du dir fühlen
Als wärst du in einem Staat
In einem Todes-Valais
Der konstante Arbeitsdruck
Kann dir schmerzen
Und die Wettbewerb
Kann es schwierig zu überleben
Die Wettbewerb beginnt
Sobald du es bei Google anwendest
Du musst mit 3 Millionen Anwendern
Jährlich kämpfen
Und sie übersteuern
Nur um ein Interview zu bekommen
Was bedeutet
Ein Job bei Google zu erlangen
Ist schwieriger als Harvard zu sein
Eigentlich 20-mal schwieriger
Aber das Interview zu übernehmen
Und zu Google zu werden
Könnte nur der Anfang sein
Du arbeitest mit
Einigen der klugsten Menschen
Im Welt
Was natürlich eine
Tolle, stimulierende Erfahrung ist
Aber du wirst auch
Druck fühlen
Um sie zu verabschieden
In Bezug auf
Performance, Produktivität
Und Kreativität
Du kannst versuchen
Mit neuen Menschen zu arbeiten
Und du kannst auch
Du kannst auch
Dein Leben
Um den Weg
In die Zukunft
Beiraten
Und die ganze Zeit
Abfangen
Das würde tatsächlich
Manche Produkte von Google erklären
Ja
Das sind dann quasi
So halbe One-Man-Shows
Mit Leuten die versuchen sich immer gegenseitig zu übertreffen mit anderen Dingern
Also, ja, hier, Chad, ich glaube, ihr habt recht, ich glaube, ihr habt recht, ja, aber man sollte sich doch mal, also, guck mal, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es so ist, ja, wahrscheinlich hast du dann auch Psychologen und alles, aber muss ich mal überlegen,
also, erst schafft man die Voraussetzung dafür, dass die Leute sich quasi gegenseitig, ja, so krassen Konkurrenz haben, dass die Leute sich quasi permanent untereinander irgendwie Selbstkonkurrenz machen und dann versuchst du obendrauf irgendwelche Gespräche zu führen, dass das nicht so oft passiert, vielleicht sollte man eigentlich das eigentliche Problem mal beheben, anstatt dann irgendwelche Psychologen draufzuschmeißen, also, was weiß ich.
Also, being on a competitive team can also make it harder to get big projects and promotions, and over time it can be discouraging to operate in this circumstance, which does lead to a lot of employees company hopping to get more recognition, that brings us to our fourth point, politics kills promotions.
The next Googler named Michael Lynch said he tried his best to stick with the company, he gave his best, yet there was still no opportunity to ever get a promotion, and numerous ex-Googlers have felt this way.
Was war und was stand da?
Sekunde.
Ja, das ist ja leider bei vielen großen Dingern so.
Tech companies, it should be purely results driven, but people pleasing within Google is apparently a massive problem, people getting passed over for promotions, taking it personally, and then going on to find a new job.
This is exactly what Crystal Brick experienced, an ex-product marketing manager, who ended up leaving her six-figure job for the same reasons.
Now the question is, when people leave, where do they go? Google seems like the top, and what's next?
Well, there are many comparable companies such as Facebook or Netflix, but a sizable...
Alter, zu Facebook würde ich auch nicht gehen.
... take advantage of the fifth major reason to start a startup.
Uncle Ben from Spider-Man said it best.
With great power comes great responsibility.
What he didn't say was, with great responsibility can come extreme stress.
If even in big companies stress is inevitable, why not spend that stress on developing your own company instead?
Da ist was dran.
And if competition is inevitable, then why not compete with Google itself?
Well, one group of ex-Google employees took this very literally, and they created a new search engine called Neva.
And Neva's far and away not the only...
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
... part of ex-Googlers have created.
There's so many like Cardiogram, TextNow, Coda, Amplitude, Zenesis...
Naja, die meisten Startups, das wird ja auch nix.
... Cape, and the list is endless.
Now, it's just a fact that people ambitious enough to get into Google in the first place are probably ambitious to...
Neva's von gehört, genau.
... eventually find it more exciting...
... and worthwhile to work on their own company, chasing that same high that initially motivated them to get into Google in the first place.
Now, of course, you're going to lose the perks, company culture, benefits, and things we've been talking about this whole time.
But if your startup does fail, the perks and competitive salaries exist at almost all the big tech companies in SF,
because they're all competing for the limited pool of great software engineers.
Tech employees are notorious for company hopping, especially for higher salaries, as soon as they get bored.
And if you have Google on your resume, you better believe recruiters are going to be flooding your...
Das ist tatsächlich, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das für viele auch ein Grund ist, dass sie zu Google gehen, weil sie sich denken,
und selbst wenn ich bei Google nach einer Weile aufhöre, macht es sich einfach gut im Lebenslauf.
Und das macht es mit Sicherheit.
... inbox more than if you were a bikini model on Instagram.
And they'll be trying to get you to move to their company.
Being so in demand is no doubt a good thing.
It makes the temptation to move, though, for a pay bump, especially after having a bad day, extremely high.
Imagine if you're Google.
You're trying to steer a ship with employees jumping off every single day.
So it's an uphill battle to keep people around and get anything done.
So maybe it's not surprising Google tries to juice people as much as they can when they are still around.
Anyway, what do you think?
Is working for Google worth it?
Are the benefits just a salesman, or do they genuinely care about their employees?
Maybe the sweet spot is landing Google, staying for one year, and then leaving it on your resume to use it for your cloud and future art.
Das werden sich garantiert viele denken, so nach dem Motto, Alter, dann hau ich halt ab,
und wenn es für dich im Lebenslauf stehen und gut ist, dann schau mal, was du denken wirst, und wir sehen uns zum nächsten Mal.
Ganz ehrlich, das wäre nichts für mich, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Erstens würden die mich niemals nehmen.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal zu irgendeinem Interview eingeladen werden, aber selbst wenn, ich würde es auch nicht machen wollen.
Da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich meine, mir ist es ja jetzt schon dort, wo ich bin.
Und das ist ja wahrscheinlich im Vergleich zu Google dann wirklich Kindergarten.
Teilweise zu stressig.
Oder zu nervig.
Insofern, ne, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich muss mich hier um Stream und YouTube und sonst was kümmern können.
Geldsorgen habe ich auch keine, deswegen ist es bei mir auch nicht so, dass ich sagen müsste,
Alter, ich hänge so an meinem Job, oder ich hänge so an dieser einen Sache,
oder ich muss mich da jetzt besonders anstrengen, dass es irgendwie super gut aussieht.
Ich mache das bevorzugt, worauf ich Bock habe, und das ziemlich gut.
Ich bin nämlich selten zufrieden.
Mit irgendwelchen Sachen.
Also das muss man sagen.
Ich glaube, das merkt man manchmal auch bei irgendwelchen Bastel-Streams.
Ich habe da ganz spezielle Vorstellungen, wie was aussehen muss.
Und so diese 0815-Lösungen, die es oftmals gibt, die gefallen mir nicht.
Und die reichen mir nicht.
Und ich bastel teilweise 30 Stunden an irgendwas rum, nur um eine Sache zu verbessern, wo andere sagen würden dazu,
ey, das ist doch Kleinkram.
Also, pfff, dann drücke ich halt zweimal anstatt einmal.
Wen juckt's?
Aber das fuckt mich so ab, dass ich zweimal drücken muss.
Dass ich lieber, und 30 Stunden reichen ja nicht, dass ich lieber zwei Monate dran bastel, dass ich noch einmal drücken muss anstatt zweimal.
Ja, und so mache ich das auf der Arbeit auch.
Also ich mache vieles halt super, ähm, wie soll ich sagen so, ausführlich und korrekt.
Was ist korrekt?
Nach meiner Art und Weise korrekt.
Was jetzt nicht zwangsläufig heißt, dass das jeder so sehen müsste.
Nee, prozessoptimiert ist das bei mir eher nicht.
Prozessoptimiert wird ja heißen, ich mache das nach irgendwelchen Abläufen, die sich andere Leute auswirken.
Ich mache das nach irgendwelchen Abläufen, die sich andere Leute auswirken.
Ja, es, Perfektionismus trifft's besser, wobei es meine Ansicht von Perfektion ist und die werden wahrscheinlich viele andere nicht teilen, ja.
Es gibt, okay, ein, ein ganz, ein, ein, ein blödes Beispiel.
Ein blödes Beispiel, wo ich viel Energie reinstecke, was eigentlich keinen Sinn, keinen Sinn gibt.
Aber, also fällt mir zu ein, weil, weil ich das, weil ich das, weil ich das letztens, letztens hatte.
Okay.
Letztendlich macht's keinen Sinn.
Aber, ich bin der Meinung, dass wenn du Skripts oder Kommandozeilen-Tools hast und die ein bisschen, äh, bisschen ausführlicher sind, die sollten ein Minus-Minus-Version unterstützen.
Und es sollte ein Minus-Minus-Version sein.
Es sollte nicht Minus-V sein, es sollte nicht Minus-Version sein.
Nein, ich bin der Meinung, es sollte Minus-Minus-Version sein.
Und ich bin da letztens bei einem von uns so auf den Sack gegangen, dass das gefälligst Minus-Minus-Version sein muss.
Hahaha.
Dass er tatsächlich eingebaut hat, dass es Minus-Minus-Version als Parameter gibt, ja.
Ne, Minus-V geht nicht.
Siehste, das ist auch sowas.
Minus-V geht nicht.
Minus-V ist verbose.
In vielen Fällen.
Ich will Minus-Minus-Version haben.
Aber Minus-V und Minus-Minus-Version ist auch okay, wenn es nicht Minus-Minus-Verbose noch gibt.
Weil dann sollte es, dann sollte Minus-V, Minus-Minus, äh, V sollte Minus-Minus-Verbose sein.
Ne, das ist doch springend, das ist kein Problem.
Kannst du auch beides geben?
Egal, das sind so Dinger, ja.
Und ich, ich hab letztens beispielsweise auch was fertig gebastelt, da ging's drum, dass wir von zwei, wie beschreibe ich das?
Sag mal so, von zwei Datenbanken in eine dritte Datenbank was importieren.
So, und die dritte Datenbank hatte ein Webinterface, wo man dann gescheit filtern kann und sowas.
Und ich hab, ich hab den Import gebaut, war, ist im Prinzip relativ easy gewesen, ja.
Beide, beide anderen, Datenbank ist falsches Wort, zwei, zwei andere Web-Services.
Ja, du kannst, du kannst über eine, über zwei APIs konntest du abfragen, Daten aus dem Einsicht, in der, iiih, alter, PowerShell-Style.
Piss dich, Alter.
Geh fort.
PowerShell, iiih, das ist ja, das war ganz abartig.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, du musst jetzt einfach nur an zwei APIs drangehen und das dann über, über, über die API in die dritte Schnittstelle pumpen.
Das war, war im Prinzip easy.
Ich war fertig, es hat alles funktioniert, aber, was hab ich gemacht?
Ich hab den restlichen Tag tatsächlich ordentliche CLI-Bedienung eingebaut in das Tool.
Aktuell, also die, die starten, das erste, was ich zusammengewurschtelt hab, war im Prinzip ein Programm, das hast du gestartet und das ging hardcoded zu diesen zwei Services, hat die Sachen gepullt und in den dritten gepusht, ja.
Und das hab ich mir gedacht danach, okay, jetzt ist das fertig, jetzt funktioniert das und jetzt bauen wir noch ein minus, minus Help, minus, minus Version.
Dann bauen wir noch Parameter ein.
Minus, minus Source, minus, minus Destination.
Dann hab ich am Ende irgendwie nochmal vier Stunden dran rumgebastelt, dass das Ding ordentliche Kommandozeilenbedienung hatte.
Und ordentliche Ausgabe.
Und zwar, wir haben sogar mittlerweile, stellt euch mal vor, du musst am Anfang dein Account und Passwort eingeben, dass du, ähm, dich bei diesem einen Webservice einloggen kannst.
Und mittlerweile ist sogar die Passworteingabe farbig.
Aber Kommandozeilenbedienung halt.
Das fragt sich hier Passwort für Service XY oder Credentials für Passwort XY eingeben.
Und sogar wenn du das Passwort eingibst, ist es ausgesternt in der Konsole.
Und das OS-unabhängig.
Also nicht einfach Readline hier unter Linux oder so in der Shell auflesen, nein, Betriebssystem unabhängig.
Gut, natürlich hab ich auch fertige Libraries dafür verwendet.
Also wer .NET verwendet, dem kann ich immer nur empfehlen, das hier zu verwenden für Kommandozeilenkrempel.
Und Kommandozeilenformatierung.
POG-Library.
Ja.
Sowas.
Also, da hab ich halt, ja, manch einer will sagen, Max, warum machst du vier Stunden an dem Tool rum, was eigentlich noch funktioniert?
Aber, tja, ich bin halt der Meinung, ich bin, das weiß ich, das widerstrebt mir dann, das so halbfertig da rumhängen zu lassen.
Und das muss dann auch Minus-Minus-Version haben und Minus-Minus-Help und Minus-H und Minus-Minus-Source und Minus-Minus-Destination und Minus-Minus-User
und ordentliche Hilfetext und ordentliche Input-Validierung und, tja.
Wechselst du wegen Manifest...
Oh, da können wir auch ein Video zugucken jetzt.
Ich hab doch irgendwo hier was offen.
Ja, das können wir uns gleich angucken.
Ja.
Also, so sieht's bei mir...
Übrigens, falls irgendjemand...
...mein Home Assistant-Add-on verwendet für seinen Fiat...
Öh.
Guckt mal, Leute, ich hab's, ich hab's weiter...
...entwickelt.
Man kann jetzt sogar sein Auto fernsteuern.
Man kann jetzt sogar an sein Auto Befehle schicken.
Nämlich...
Äh.
Man kann an sein Auto jetzt nämlich Befehle schicken.
Man kann GPS-Location updaten, Batteriestatus updaten, man kann die Lichter blinken lassen, man kann das Laden starten, man kann den Kofferraum öffnen oder man kann die Klimaanlage einschalten.
Remote.
Mit der Integration hier.
Ach ja, übrigens.
Wisst ihr, was bei Fiat äußerst pepega ist?
Was sehr, sehr merkwürdig ist bei Fiat.
Ähm.
Man kann...
Man kann das Preconditioning vom Auto, also quasi die Temperatur, die man eingestellt hat, kann man einschalten.
Aber man kann es offiziell nicht wieder ausschalten.
Also sprich, wer die offizielle Fiat-App verwendet, der kann nur sagen, bitte Auto jetzt heizen.
Und die Heizung danach nicht wieder ausschalten, außer er setzt sich ins Auto und drückt aus.
Und ich hab was gefunden.
Ich hab nen Befehl gefunden.
Ehrlich gesagt im dekompilierten Android-App-Source.
Das wollte ich hier aber nicht On-Stream machen.
Ich hab nen Befehl gefunden, um das angeblich wieder auszuschalten.
Aber ich weiß halt nicht, was es macht.
Deswegen hab ich das rausgelassen.
Deswegen musst du erstmal ne Option setzen, wenn man das verwenden will.
Wie ist das gesichert?
Sollte nicht von jedem einsehbar sein.
Wenn du das Add-On installierst, musst du dein Passwort und dein Account für die Fiat-Webseite eingeben.
Das geht über nen Online-Service.
Und ein PIN musst du eingeben.
Leute, ich hab ein Problem. Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Pepo Pupu.
Sekunde, Leute.
Ich bin...
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Afg... Afg Klo.
Zwei, drei Minuten.
Hey.
Wieder am Start.
Hast du eines deiner ESP-Projekte Akku betrieben?
Ja, habe ich.
Wobei ich das nie im Einsatz hatte.
Aber es hätte funktioniert.
Ich hab mal nen LoRa-Sensor gebaut.
Mit Akku.
Mit so ner 1200mAh-Akku-Block.
Ja, ich kann was empfehlen.
Du brauchst nen ESP, der Low-Power ist im Deep-Sleep.
Ich kann dir das Ding dafür empfehlen.
Wenn es das noch gibt.
Das Board ist nicht schlecht dafür.
Das ist Low-Power. Das verbraucht bloß irgendwie 10 uA im Deep-Sleep.
Das schaltet alles mögliche aus.
Das ist ein gutes Low-Power.
Fragt mich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Wie investierst du eigentlich deine ganze Kohle?
Ich hab...
ETFs.
Die sind aber schlecht dieses Jahr.
Zwischenzeitlich mal wieder im Plus.
Aber jetzt wieder...
Ich guck mal kurz in die App rein.
Minus 2300 Euro.
Ja.
Fast so tief wie im Mai.
Apple ging gut ab.
Ach, ne Moment. Das ist das Jahr. Weak.
Es ist ja alles Minus.
Es hat diese Woche nichts Plus.
Nichts hat Plus.
Eigentlich könnte ich jetzt nochmal ne Runde kaufen, oder?
Keck.
Auf geht's.
Ja, du hast zu ner wahrscheinlich ganz guten Zeit angefangen.
Weil irgendwann geht's auch mal wieder rauf.
Das Gute ist, ich muss den Kram nicht verkaufen oder so.
Weil ich hab noch ein bisschen...
Ich hab noch genug Kohle so für kurzzeitige Sachen.
Auf dem Konto rumliegen.
Das heißt, selbst wenn ich jetzt mal schnell was brauche, ich hab erstmal was.
Das heißt, meine ETFs kann ich da jetzt jahrelang rumschimmeln lassen.
Und dann hoffentlich Big Stonks haben.
Ja, ist auch das einzig Sinnvolle.
Weil sonst wärst du jetzt gezwungen, da irgendwas rauszuholen.
Und dann wär halt richtig...
Minus ist es ja erst, wenn du es verkaufst.
So, was wollte ich mir angucken?
Google will soon kill Adblockers.
Mit Manifest V3.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Na, die Antwort ist ganz einfach.
Wenn's gar zu abfuck wird, Firefox verwenden.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich hab jetzt schon irgendwo gelesen, dass es angeblich noch ein Jahr weiter verschoben wurde.
World ETF.
Das ist ein, ich sag's dir genau...
Emerging Markets hätte ich machen sollen.
Aber jetzt weiß ich auch nicht mehr.
Das ist der...
Tja.
Ist doch ziemlich bescheuert, Alter.
Die Broker-Apps golden.
Hier.
Start FTSE All World ETF.
Accumulating.
Also, wird nichts ausgezahlt.
Wird alles wieder reingesteckt.
Wurscht.
Mal gucken.
So, schauen wir uns das mal an.
Meistens kann ich mir nur die ersten drei Minuten von ihm geben, weil der Rest immer übelst skarante ist gegen irgendwas.
Thesaurierend.
Oder wie auch immer man das auf Deutsch ausspricht.
Ja.
Auf geht's.
Schauen wir uns mal an, was macht Google wieder.
Da will ich übrigens auch noch ein Video zu machen.
Ich hab sehr viele Sachen aktuell, wo ich nicht mit hinterher komme.
Der verwendet bestimmt auch Arch, by the way, oder?
...Ads, that will be coming to certain browsers.
So, to give you a quick rundown of the situation.
Right now, a lot of extensions, especially ad blockers, are using the older Manifest V2 framework,
which is browser agnostic, by the way.
So, both Chrome and Firefox extensions use these frameworks.
But in January of 2023, Chrome is going to completely disable Manifest V2's APIs.
Now, Google...
Ich hab aber gelesen, es gibt schon eine Adblock, eine U-Block-Version für Manifest V3,
die aber wohl nicht so viel kann wie Manifest V2.
Also, es gibt...
Es gibt jetzt irgendwie U-Block Origin für V2 und U-Block Origin für V3.
The excuse for doing this is to provide you with more security and safety.
Ja gut, das ist Blödsinn.
Since one of the changes coming with Manifest...
Ich mein, vielleicht, aber hauptsächlich ist es, dass Google Geld machen kann.
So wie bei so ziemlich allem.
...is that extensions won't be able to load remotely hosted code anymore.
And look, I gotta be honest, changing this...
Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, Änderung bei sowas ist immer nur, um mehr Geld zu machen.
...probably is going to bring some people some security.
Because as we've seen on this channel several times,
there is people out there that install malicious extensions and then get hacked through them.
Like, lots of people do this. I don't know why.
But yeah, that change is kind of like a childproof lock for them, I guess.
Könnten sich ja auch einfach mal ihren Google Add-on Store ein bisschen zu Brust nehmen,
weil da so viel Shit drin ist teilweise, was einfach schon nach Scam schreit.
...from the API changes that are going to kill ad blockers and user script managers like Tampermonkey.
So I'm not buying the safety excuse.
I mean, I don't ever really buy the safety excuse when people say,
oh, we have to take away some things for your safety.
No, it's always a lie, okay?
Zum größten Teil zumindest, ja.
...since Google makes billions of dollars from serving ads and collecting user info.
So it's pretty easy to figure out the real reason for this.
So, what is 2023 going to look like?
Are we all going to live in the pod, consume the ads and be forced to be happy?
Well, if you're using Chrome and you just decide to sit around like a bump on a log,
and like Google will abuse you, then of course,
you're going to be abused more and more,
and take Firefox or any of its forks.
A lot of people still don't really seem to realize that most browsers out there,
they're just forks of Chrome.
They use Chromes Web-
Wobei das nicht zwangsläufig heißen muss, dass die auch irgendwelche Sachen mit Manifest und so machen.
Wie Valdi zum Beispiel, die haben schon gesagt, sie unterstützen...
Die unterstützen Manifest V2 weiter.
Außerdem sagen sie, sie haben eingebauten Adblocker.
Die Extensions werden gekokt.
Kokt ihr auch immer Extensions?
Ja, bei Chromium bin ich mal gespannt, ob es da nicht ein eigenes Bild geben wird, wo das wieder aktiviert ist.
Ist Chrome.
Ja, wissen wir.
Brave, weiß ich nicht, habe ich nie die Begeisterung für verstanden.
Ist Brave nicht China-Chinesenkram?
Sekunde.
Brave-Browser.
Nee.
Ist es nicht.
Ach nee, Opera.
Opera, sorry.
Jetzt habe ich Durchleiner gebracht.
Opera ist China-Chinesenkram.
Brave, Brave ist nicht China-Chinesenkram.
Ja.
Nee, das ist, das ist, das ist...
Ich habe, ich habe an Opera gedacht.
Brave ist doch von dem der JavaScript entwickelt hat.
Ja, glaubt schon.
Oder von einem davon.
Okay.
Firefox ist top.
Ich glaube, bei Firefox ist es ein bisschen komisch.
Aber die meisten Leute...
Na ja, man muss sagen, Firefox war am Start eigentlich schon lange, bevor Chrome am Start war.
Chrome hat halt durch die pure Präsenz und Google letztendlich diesen Anteil.
Firefox ist ein absolut sinnvoller, guter Browser.
Was ich halt...
Mein persönliches Problem mit Firefox ist eher, dass Firefox irgendwie so keine...
Linie in der Entwicklung drin hat.
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Also, Firefox ist eigentlich der Browser für Leute, die ein bisschen mehr mit ihrem Browser machen wollen.
Ja, die ein bisschen, die, die ein bisschen Technik interessiert sind und sonst was.
Aber sie haben über die letzten Jahre hinweg quasi das total vernachlässigt und ihn immer, immer mehr beschnitten in allen Bereichen.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal dieses verkackte Menü an für einen Desktop-Browser.
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder?
Allein schon, wenn ich, wenn ich dieses, dieses Kack-Menü zum Bedienen hier sehe, reicht mir schon.
Und...
Ich, ich versteh...
Die haben auch vor einer Weile alle, alle Add-ons mal kaputt gemacht.
Weil eines der riesen Vorteile von Firefox ist ja eben, dass, ähm, du dort viele Add-ons hattest, die halt viel konnten.
Beziehungsweise in anderen Browsern nicht möglich waren.
Erinnert sich noch einer alt, das alte, das alte NoScript zum Beispiel.
Und das wurde auf einen Schritt...
Und das wurde auf einen Schlag quasi damals schon auch, äh, nicht funktionierend mehr gepatcht.
Ja.
People that are saying like, oh, Firefox just doesn't work, you know, all the websites are broken.
They're living in the past. They're like in 2005 or something, okay?
Like, Firefox and Chrome, they're basically equal in terms of like how browsing the web would work for...
Aber wenn es wirklich Probleme gibt, ja, ohne Scheiß, also wenn es wirklich so ist, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert,
beziehungsweise ich mir jetzt Webseiten mit Ads angucken muss, dann werde ich einfach überall Firefox verwenden.
Und jetzt mal ernsthaft, wir können wirklich froh sein, dass es Firefox gibt.
Weil es gibt, wenn man so, man kann die großen Browser-Engines, kannst du an drei Händen abzählen.
Es gibt Chrome, wobei es ist ja eigentlich, äh, Bling, Bling, Blink oder so heißt der Kampel ja intern.
Also du hast Chrome.
Du hast, ähm, WebKit.
Das ist Safari.
Und du hast, Gecko heißt das glaube ich, das ist Firefox.
Fertig.
Also du hast Chrome-based, Firefox und Safari.
Und wir können, und Safari kannst du knicken.
Safari ist einfach der größte Shit-Browser aller Zeiten, gerade unter iOS.
Und Firefox, leider gibt es unter iOS nur Safari und nichts anderes.
Alles andere ist Fake.
Ähm, Fake Safari im Endeffekt.
Also wer, wer iOS benutzt, muss Safari benutzen, anders geht's nicht.
Ähm, das heißt, wir können wirklich froh sein, dass es so was wie Firefox gibt.
Weil Firefox ist tatsächlich der letzte übrig gebliebene Browser, der nicht Apple oder Google ist im Endeffekt.
Also, der wirklich eine Alternative ist, wenn die irgendwie wieder am Rad drehen.
Und auch für einen Entwickler.
Ich meine, aus meiner Erfahrung mit Web-Development, habe ich mich wirklich nicht gezwungen,
Chrome zu nutzen.
Ich kann trotzdem die meisten Dinge in Firefox machen.
Aber trotzdem, zurück zu Brave.
Die Ad-Blocking sollte nach Januar weiter funktionieren.
Und ich habe auch gehört, dass Brave die Enterprise-Policy auf ihrem Chromium-Fork starten könnte,
was auch den Tod von Manifest V2 bis Juni 2023 verlängern wird.
Also Extensions wie Tampermonkey sollten weiterhin funktionieren, wenn sie das wählen.
Also switchen zu Brave, das könnte eine Lösung sein.
Nee, also bevor ich zu Brave switche, verwende ich lieber wieder Firefox.
Ich meine, ich habe Firefox drauf, ich verwende Firefox beispielsweise für mein komplettes YouTube-Zeug immer noch.
Dann verwende ich Firefox, warum nicht?
I want you guys to understand that it's still based on Chrome.
So it may be vulnerable to other methods that Google could use later on to kill Ad-Blocking.
Remember, this is their cash cow.
This is the real reason that they're doing Manifest V3
and that they want to completely deprecate Manifest V2.
Unless Brave is able to change their browser's engine to something totally different.
Was ist denn das hier für ein Browser?
Ist das nicht das Ding vom Atom-Editor?
Ach so.
Ach nee, das sind browser-based Programme, die er hier hat.
Ach ja, okay, jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Ja, ja, Discord, Discord, Teams, Spotify.
Brave, Visual Studio, was haben wir hier noch?
Chrome, Opera, Edge.
Was ist denn das?
Ist das Zoom?
Nee, was ist denn das da unten?
Was ist denn das hier?
Ach, Slack, ja.
Ja, stimmt, ihr habt recht, Leute, es ist Slack.
Alles schon verdrängt.
Ja, Slack.
Now, what if you don't want to change your browser?
Okay, maybe you're somebody that just hates change.
Even more than you hate the abuse that Google...
Stimmt, das meinte ich, genau, uBlock Origin Lite gibt es jetzt.
Wobei das halt wohl nur mit eingebauten Filterlisten irgendwie kommt
und wohl irgendwie halt nicht so viel machen kann wie das andere,
Standard uBlock Origin jetzt.
...doing to you and you're not even willing to switch to another Chromium browser like Brave.
Well, there will still be adblockers that are built
with the Manifest V3 APIs.
In fact, Raymond Hill, the lead developer of uBlock Origin,
recently released uBlock Origin Lite,
which was formerly called uBlock Origin Minus,
kind of still has a logo from that,
which is an adblocker completely built with the Manifest V3 Framework.
Das ist eigentlich ein richtiges 5-Head-Logo.
This is an adblocker that you could use on Chrome in 2023.
Kennt jemand ein gutes Programm zum MP3 verwalten?
Also du willst keinen Player, du willst einen MP3-Manager, oder was?
...both the current name and the former name.
Ich habe früher immer FUBA 2000 verwendet als Player.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
GitHub? Gibt es, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr, oder?
Snap? MonkaS, Alter.
Ih, wer will denn das als Snap installieren?
Snap. Guck mal, wie das aussieht.
Also das ist irgendeine Ubuntu-Version davon.
...ad and tracker blocking capability than the original uBlock Origin.
Okay, it's just not as good as the original thing.
Ja.
And it may also be a little bit...
Weiter, weiter.
...you will get something...
...adblocking from Firefox...
Also es ist ganz einfach.
Wenn das wirklich so dazu führt,
dass uBlock und alles Mögliche dann mal ordentlich funktioniert,
dann wird einfach wieder Firefox verwendet.
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als wäre es die Wahnsinnsumgewöhnung.
Firefox und Chrome...
Also...
Ich glaube, jeder, der mit dem einen klarkommt,
kommt auch mit dem anderen klar.
Dann machen wir keck bei Chrome,
wenn das wirklich so kommt.
Ich habe jetzt allerdings auch schon gelesen,
dass Manifest V3 angeblich doch erst 2024 kommen soll.
Genau.
Die haben nämlich wieder zurückgerudert.
Weil zu viel Shitstorm.
Ich...
Wie gesagt, dazu wollte ich auch noch ein Video machen.
Ich komme aktuell mit Videomachen nicht hinterher.
Ich habe jetzt...
Muss man sich mal angucken.
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich...
Guck mal hier, in den letzten 14 Tagen...
Für mich ist das schon wirklich viel.
Also in den letzten 14 Tagen habe ich 5 Videos gemacht.
Und hier allein schon...
Guck mal, letzte Woche 3 Videos.
Kackel, Alter.
Das ist für mich total viel.
Opera GX.
Ich sehe die Anwendungsberechtigung,
die Daseinsberechtigung für Opera GX.
Das Genshin Sponsoring war überzeugend.
Ja, fand ich auch.
Leute, Leute.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Ich habe mir so schwer getan,
Leute,
das in 90 Sekunden einzusprechen.
Das ist so viel Text.
Das war eine komplette A4-Seite voll.
Pass, pass, pass.
Ich...
Ich konnte mich gerade noch so zusammenreißen, weil der Text so cringe war.
Oh man.
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, wenn man auf solche Games steht, so schlecht ist Genshin wirklich nicht.
Der Friseur hat das beispielsweise rauf und runter gecrined eine ganze Weile.
Es ist halt wieder so China-Chinesen-Glücksspiel-Zeug.
Aber an sich, im Kern, ist es, glaube ich, gar nicht verkehrt, dass sie das abgenommen haben.
Leute, ihr glaubt nicht, was sie daran rumgemeckert haben, bis sie das abgenommen haben.
Jedes, hier.
Hallo Leute.
Die wollten, irgendwo ist es verständlich, ja.
Wenn man da schon Geld für bezahlt, ich verstehe es ja.
Also, das Placement des QR-Codes, die Reihenfolge der Charaktere.
Wie die gezeigt werden, war Pflicht.
Die Bilder, die hier am Ende gezeigt werden, waren Pflicht.
Die Anordnung der Bilder war Pflicht.
Ähm, ja.
Äh, der Code war Pflicht.
Das Einblenden 60x Primo Gems und 5x Adventure Books war Pflicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was es heißt, aber ist so, ja.
Also, die waren wirklich sehr, ähm, hatten sehr genaue Vorstellungen, wie das aussieht.
Wie das auszusehen hat.
Nee, der Text ist nicht egal.
Ich hab, also, es war so.
Ich hab erst was aufgenommen.
Was ich eigentlich fand, der hat sich ganz gut angehört.
Und dann haben die das komplett umgeschrieben und daraus einen, einen, einen, den da vier Seiten langen Werbetext gemacht.
Und ich hab auch gesagt, Leute, das kann ich doch nicht in der Minute oder in eineinhalb Minuten erzählen.
Und dann haben die gemeint, doch, ungekürzt wäre am besten.
Und dann hab ich's halt einfach runtergerattert.
Was soll ich machen?
Und ich hab gesagt, ja, hier, guck da.
Ja, Probe hören.
Haben sie gemeint, ja, ist gut so.
Und dann hab ich mir, okay, wenn das gut so ist, dann lassen wir das halt so.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist es sogar besser, wenn ich Werbetexte so runterratter.
Weil dann bringt das keiner so wirklich mit mir in Verbindung, dass es jetzt, dass es meine persönliche Empfehlung wäre.
Es ist halt so, wie wenn irgendwie sich irgendein Fußballer hinstellt und Werbung macht für Snickers oder so.
Oder, oder für irgendwelche komischen Haar, ähm, Haarwachstum.
Wachsmittel oder sowas, ja, wo sie sagen, oh, mein Haar ist jetzt so, oh Mann, so.
Wo ich mir auch so denke, ja, Alter, ihr wisst noch nicht mal, was ihr da eigentlich in die Kamera haltet.
Aber warum, ist doch egal.
Also insofern ist das für mich wahrscheinlich sogar besser, wenn ich das so vorlese.
Habt ihr vor Twitch manchmal auch so absolute Cringe-Rewe-Werbung in letzter Zeit?
Irgend so einen Typ, der noch älter ist als ich, der dann, der noch älter ist als ich.
Und dann irgendwie sowas sagt wie OMG WTF in der Werbung.
Richtig cringe, Alter, wer hat sich das...
Welche Werbeagentur hat sich das denn schon wieder ausgedacht?
Mega Upload, ja, Meg, Meg...
Moment, Moment.
Wo wir grad, wo wir grad dabei sind.
Hatten wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr, aber ist das auch gut.
Ist auch gut.
Der Mega Upload Song.
Ich fand den gar nicht schlecht.
It's fixed.
Was für ein Ding?
Wim, wim, win.
Wie, was, wie spricht man das überhaupt aus?
Wie, wie, wie...
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das sein soll.
Ist das noch ein Ding? Keine Ahnung.
Also Mega Upload nicht. Mega Upload ist dicht.
Und der Nachfolger Mega hat er ja verkauft.
An irgendwelchen China-Chinesen, glaube ich.
Was macht der jetzt eigentlich?
Der langsame Tod der Trends.
Okay, was? Wir haben uns noch gar nicht Level-Captcha-Baden lassen.
Ich bin siegl.
Paper Mario.
Ups.
Ähm.
Was, was hat er denn uns zu erzählen, Level-Capt?
Wir hören uns das jetzt immer kurz vor.
Battlefield. Latest Updates makes good progress.
Okay.
Finals Playtest.
Juckt mich nicht.
Warte.
Ne, juckt...
Ha!
Skulls and Bones.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das überhaupt noch in Entwicklung ist.
Juckt mich nicht.
Äh, haben wir uns schon drüber ausgelassen?
Ja, juckt mich auch nicht, weil so wirklich, die haben das Game seit irgendwie...
Das Game ist ja irgendwie auch in 10 Jahren gefühlt in Entwicklung jetzt schon, ja?
Dann wurde es zwischenzeitlich mal eingestellt, dann wurde es von irgendeinem anderen wieder gekauft
und dann haben sie jetzt irgendwie ein Jahr lang zu spät ihre Beta gelauncht und...
Wir gucken mal kurz.
Steam-Stats.
Hey!
Das hat ungefähr so viele Spieler wie Battlefield 2042.
Braucht man immer noch Mail.ru-Anti-Cheat?
Anti-Cheat.
Mail.ru hatten die vorher.
Mail.ru-Anti-Cheat.
Ich wusste, wie gesagt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass es Mail.ru überhaupt gibt.
Das ist Game of Anti-Cheat.
Mail.ru-Anti-Cheat.
Da habe ich schon mal keinen Bock drauf.
Wirst du Overwatch 2 reinschauen?
Ja, allerdings nicht im Stream.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich ein paar Runden spielen.
Mal gucken, ob ich ein paar von meinen ehemaligen...
Team-Kollegen in Overwatch reaktivieren kann dazu.
Wenn es vor drei Monaten war.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die da nochmal irgendwie ihre Anti-Cheat-Engine ausgetauscht haben.
Aber ich werde es mir auf jeden Fall ein paar Runden angucken.
Und vor allem, wie die Microtransactions und sowas integriert sind in dem Spiel.
Weil das ist halt die Gefahr.
An sich finde ich es eine gute Sache, das Free-to-Play zu machen.
Auch gerade langfristig.
Und Content-Versorgung und alles.
Ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass es Blizzard wieder verkackt.
Weil ich meine, was hat Blizzard die letzten Jahre über nicht verkackt?
Und dass sie die Transactions halt wieder total verkacken.
So nach dem Motto, du kannst Premium-Währung kaufen, Premium-Dings kaufen, schnellere Q-Times kaufen, was weiß ich, 5 In-Game-Währungen und Skins für 8,90 Euro das Stück und sowas.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, Blizzard wird es in irgendeiner Art und Weise verkacken.
Sonst werden sie wieder richtig, richtig hart verkacken.
Was mich tatsächlich interessiert, was aus dem Single-Player geworden ist, den es ja mal fett angekündigt gab für Overwatch 2.
Ob es den komplett gestrichen wurde oder sonst wie was.
Ich habe nie wieder was von gehört.
Ganz ehrlich, eine Overwatch-Kampagne wäre wirklich nice.
Und ich sage euch, Blizzard früher hätte sicherlich eine gute Overwatch-Kampagne zusammengezimmert.
Weil Overwatch hat tatsächlich eins, was vielen Games fehlt.
Oder?
Also Overwatch hatte, das hat sich auch ein bisschen verwässert, aber Overwatch hatte in gewisser Weise Charakter.
Also das hatte einen eigenen Stil, das hatte wieder erkennbare Charaktere, Charaktere, die die Leute mochten, die quasi kaum Hintergrundgeschichte hatten und trotzdem irgendwie herausgestochen sind.
Also das wäre quasi wie gemacht für eine Kampagne.
Es wäre auch wie gemacht für eine Videoserie, wenn die das denn auf die Reiche haben.
Blizzard, weiß ich nicht.
Also gerade viele Casuals, die stehen nicht auf Ultra-Competitive-Multiplayer-Shit.
Die wollen, die wollen, guck mal, sogar in Valorant, sogar in Valorant, Alter.
Die Leute gucken sich irgendwelche Lore-Trailer und sowas an und diskutieren dann darüber, ob nicht, was weiß ich, der Charakter was mit dem hat.
Und vor allem, diese Diskussionen sind immer so sinnlos, aber das interessiert die Leute, ja.
Aber Blizzard hat es Lore-Technisch auch in Overwatch nicht hingekriegt.
Die haben ein paar Kurzfilme gebracht, die alle cool waren.
Der bestische Kurzfilm ist nach wie vor der beste, finde ich.
Und danach kam einfach jahrelang jetzt nix.
Also ich, wie gesagt, Blizzard hat die letzten Jahre über so viel verkackt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, die verkacken es mit Overwatch 2 auch.
Leider.
Der langsame Tod der Trends.
Okay.
Zehn nützliche Shortcuts für Computer.
Oh, das ist bestimmt wieder...
Und Battlefield gucken wir heute nicht, hab ich keinen Bock.
Lohnt sich das?
Gucken wir jetzt.
Gibt's da irgendwas Spannendes?
Berechnung, wie viel man für die...
Wahrscheinlich ultra viel, ja.
Okay, der langsame Tod der Trends.
Das klingt doch eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Zeig mal her.
Das aktuelle Versteck der Trends.
Naja, wir haben das aktuelle Versteck ja gefunden.
Man geht einfach unter Explore und dann geht man auf Trending und dann geht man beispielsweise auf Gaming.
Ich mein, die YouTube-Bedienung war schon immer ziemlich, ziemlich Painschamp, was das angeht.
Niemand von euch kann mir die genauen aktuellen...
...Klickwege nennen, die von diesem Video aus nötig sind, um in die YouTube-Trends zu kommen.
Doch.
Hab ich doch gerade gezeigt.
So.
Oh.
Easy.
Weiß gar nicht, was er hat.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Allerdings, gut, hätte ich nicht zufälligerweise vorher in die Trends geguckt, hätte ich's auch nicht gefunden.
Und das ist auch kein Umstand, für den man sich selbst bemitleiden müsste.
Schließlich wird einem die Navigation dahin immer schwieriger gemacht.
Zu YouTubes Anfängen hießen sie noch gar nicht Trends, weil sie stattdessen einfach die gesamte Startseite waren.
Ja, Leute.
Von...
Wisst ihr, welches Video von mir auf der Startseite mal gewesen ist für längere Zeit?
Und ich mich bis heute frage, warum, und ich immer noch nicht weiß, was der Sinn dahinter war?
Hallo, Junge.
Zwo Millionen Views.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum. Wirklich nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Absolut keine Ahnung.
Warum dieses Video in den Trends war, beziehungsweise auf der Startseite damals.
Von YouTubern hörte man damals immer wieder Sätze wie
Mega krass, mein Video wird auf der Startseite gezeigt.
Noch vor drei Jahren bildeten die Trends die Kopfzeile der Startseite.
Und da die Videos in dieser Liste für eine Sprachregion festgelegt waren, wurde man,
wenn man dort mit dem eigenen Video gelistet war, auch mit entsprechend höheren Aufrufzahlen überschüttet.
Bis Mitte 2021 waren die Trends immerhin noch auf der Startseite.
Aber weiter unten...
Die Trends waren sogar so effektiv darin, Kanälen ein größeres Publikum zu bescheren,
dass einige Leute angefangen haben, Gewinnspiele zu veranstalten oder, nur so zu tun,
Gewinnchancen an nicht nachprüfbare Interaktionen mit dem Video koppelten,
damit sie möglichst weit oben für möglichst lange Zeit in den Trends gelistet waren.
Oder man hat es damals wie Simon Desue gemacht und hat einfach komische Gewinnspiele und Sachen gemacht.
Und ich weiß gar nicht...
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es genau war.
Und dann einfach gesagt, nö, das Preisgeld gibt es nicht.
Um in die Trends zu kommen, erstmal nach links auf den Unterpunkt Entdecken klicken.
Das ist schon mal eine Sache, die ich noch nie zuvor getan habe.
Dort hat man dann zur Hälfte schon die Trends, aber auch nicht wirklich, denn...
Man kann nochmal auf Trends drücken.
...auf das Händchen namens Trends, offenbaren sich gleich vier unterschiedliche Listen,
die mittlerweile alle als Trends bezeichnet werden.
Filme, Gaming...
1000 Euro und Xbox, genau das war es.
Stimmt, jetzt...
Ich sehe, ihr erinnert euch da noch dran.
Erinnert sich noch einer?
Ah, den Bombenprank von ApoRed.
Oh, die Leute auf YouTube, Alter, teilweise.
Der Insi-Modus.
Damals war der Insi-Modus noch nicht aktiviert.
Musik und aktuell, weil Rest wahrscheinlich nicht so attraktiv klang.
Und dass die Trends in YouTubes Design so tief verborgen sind, ist natürlich kein Zufall.
Das ist ganz bewusst.
Wirft aber die Frage auf, wie viel Relevanz diese Funktion noch hat.
Naja...
Vor ein paar Monaten hat mich...
...ein paar Monate...
...ich gucke nie in die Trends.
...PopBubble angeschrieben.
Gesagt, er hätte zusammen mit seinem Team über das vergangene Jahr die Trends jedes einzelnen Tag...
Moment, das kommt mir bekannt vor.
...und würde diese Daten gerne mit mir auswählen.
Das haben wir vorhin geguckt.
Daraus entstanden nun zwei Videos.
Seins, dass sich um die Relevanz der YouTuber dreht, die sich durch diese Daten ermitteln lässt, quasi, was die Trends über Deutschlands YouTube-Landschaft aussagen.
Kennen wir schon.
Und meins, dass sich um die durch diese Daten festzustellende Relevanz der Trends auf der gesamten Plattform dreht.
Wer eben richtig zugehört hat, wird wissen, dass 2021...
Das wissen wir doch schon.
...eine ungewöhnliche Umbaumaßnahme für die Trends stattfand.
Und dann haben wir angefangen, die Daten zu begutachten, zu schauen, was sich für Auffälligkeiten finden lassen.
Zum Beispiel, dass...
Boah, nee, da hab ich jetzt eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Das haben wir doch alles schon.
Haben wir doch mehr oder weniger.
Alle schon geguckt.
Nochmal.
Nochmal muss nicht sein.
Kurz ein bisschen Tee trinken.
Wie ist es eigentlich, dass sich das Wort Klimaleugner irgendwie kein...
Dass es irgendwie keinen Sinn ergibt?
Ich mein, fällt mir grad...
Warum...
Wie kann man das Klima leugnen?
Das müsste eher sowas heißen wie irgendwie...
Klimawandel...
Wie soll man es gescheit nennen?
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich ist es doch die Pest...
Weitere Abkürzung.
Es müsste halt irgendwie das ein bisschen genauer beschreiben.
Weil ich mein, das Klima an sich kann ja wohl keiner leugnen.
Man muss einfach nur aus dem Fenster gucken.
Das ist genauso wie Wetterleugner.
Ähm...
Es regnet.
Nee, nee, ich leugne, dass es regnet.
Genau.
Das müsste...
Da müsste es eigentlich irgendeinen anderen, griffigeren Begriff für geben.
Abstre...
Also Klimawandelabstreiter oder sowas.
Oder Klimawandelleugner vielleicht noch.
Wobei, ich glaube, es leugnet ja keiner so wirklich aktuell.
Oder gut, paar Verrückte gibt es immer noch.
Aber wo sich ja manche immer noch dran aufhängen, ist so nach dem Motto...
Ja, einen Klimawandel gibt es.
Aber die Menschen haben damit nichts zu tun.
Das gibt es ja immer noch.
Wo man sich tatsächlich drüber streiten kann, ist natürlich...
In welchem Ausmaß und wie das Ganze verläuft.
Weil das geht ja auch prognosentechnisch enorm weit auseinander.
Ich glaube, um die Existenz, dass es...
Da...
Das kann ja eigentlich keiner mehr wirklich leugnen.
Klimawandel ungläubig.
Ja, das wird...
Na, ungläubig, das hört sich dann so religiös schon an.
Fuck for fun.
Kann man ja machen.
Aber gleichzeitig auch gegen Verhütung ist dann...
Gut, man kann sein Leben auch komplett wegschmeißen dann und sagen...
Ach ja, ist egal, auf geht's.
20 Kinder, easy.
Ach, die sollen alle machen, was sie wollen.
Gaming Laptop.
Trap.
Was soll denn da die Trap sein?
Gaming Laptops sind halt in der Regel...
Naja, nix für mich.
Sag mal, irgendwie kommen wirklich immer exakt die gleichen Videos hier in der Empfehlung.
Was ist denn das?
How overemployed...
Multiple fulltime salaries.
Na, auf geht's.
Das ist aber anstrengend.
Da hab ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Da mach ich lieber noch paar Genshin Impact Sponsorings.
Haben wir nicht mal irgendwas Entspannendes hier?
Free Never Obsolete PC.
Oh, olle PC-Handwerk.
Genau das Richtige für mich.
So sehen für mich noch Desktop-PCs aus.
Graue, weiße oder cremefarbene Tower-Gehäuse.
Ja, das ist was.
Das ist genau das Richtige für mich.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Boomer-Alarm.
Genau das Richtige für mich.
Sehr schön.
Zeig her.
Greetings.
And today on LGR we have this debatably enjoyable, new to me old computer that I'm unjustifiably excited to have.
The E-Machines E-Tower 5.
Das, die, die, guck mal Leute.
Das ist noch aus Zeiten, wo es AGP-Graphics gab.
Ein 56K-Fax-Modem.
Und tatsächlich schon, das hat sich eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich großartig lange überschnitten,
ein CD-Brenner und nicht nur ein CD.
Sondern ein re-writable CD-Brenner.
Das war der Shit damals.
... of 66 IR from the year 2000.
One with the infamous never-absolute...
2000 gab es schon so schnelle Rechner?
... delete sticker...
566, stehe ich mal davon aus.
566, das waren Pentium III?
Gab es die 2000 schon?
Also ich weiß.
Ich habe mir, ungefähr zu Half-Life Release, das war so 98 rum,
habe ich mir einen Rechner gekauft mit einem Pentium II, 400 MHz.
Ja doch, kommt hin.
Klar, kommt hin.
Eineinhalb bis zwei Jahre später dann das Ding.
Ja klar, doch kommt hin.
Never obsolete.
Alles klar.
Ah, das war ein Celeron.
Leute, die Dinger...
waren richtig geil.
Diese 5666 MHz Celeron, die konntest du nämlich extremst heftig übertakten.
Die konntest du mega übertakten, die Dinger.
Das könnte sogar sein...
Ne, ne, Leute, ich glaube, die etwas langsameren waren es noch.
Die konntest du teilweise doppelt bis zweieinhalbfache übertakten.
Das ging richtig ab damals.
Da haben die Leute sogar sich für Gaming-PCs absichtlich Celerons gekauft,
weil die halt...
rein takt-technisch viel, viel höher liefen, als die teureren.
Ein Vintage-Computer-Festival, das war's für mich, ja.
Das ist was für...
Das ist was für Boomer, die noch nicht wirklich Boomer sind, aber doch äh... älter schon.
... importe Maschinen und so weiter.
Da gab es das.
Ich spreche einfach mit Leuten, die sagen,
ja, da ist ein unglaublicher Twiggy-Apple-Lisa da drüben,
aber habt ihr das komplette Jahr 2000 E-Machines-E-Tower gesehen,
mit all den originalen Stickern?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe seit Jahren für ein solches komplettes Setup geschaut.
Also, das war mein...
Ich frage mich, was der Typ damit macht, ja.
Der hat, der hat daheim irgendwie 60 solcher Oldschool-Computer.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der...
Warum?
Also, was macht der? Der macht da ein Video drüber, okay, aber...
Und dann?
Ja.
Ah, der gute Windows-95-Bildschirm-Schoner.
Haken auf einen 14-Zoll-Monitor.
Nicht nur auf einen 14-Zoll-Monitor.
Eines der Probleme damals war auch, dass, wenn du größere Monitore hattest, ja,
die dann auch ein bisschen höhere Auflösungen hatten,
die konntest du dann bloß teilweise mit 60 Hertz ansprechen.
Und Leute, ihr könnt euch das nicht mehr vorstellen.
Die Generation heute kennt das ja nicht mehr.
Wisst ihr, wie eklig ein 60-Hertz-Monitor war?
Das kannst du nicht mit einem 60-Hertz-CRT...
Äh, kannst du nicht mit einem 60-Hertz...
Du kannst ein 60-Hertz-CRT nicht mit einem 60-Hertz-LCD vergleichen.
60-Hertz-CRT hat geblimmert.
Wie verrückt.
Da ist dir schlecht geworden von nach ein paar Stunden.
Das war damals auch so ein Ding.
Da haben ganz viele komplett PC-Hersteller so Tastaturen mitgeliefert
mit irgendwelchen total unsinnigen Funktionen.
Das weiß ich noch.
Ich hatte damals zusätzlich...
Ich hatte damals ein Microsoft Office Keyboard.
Dieses Teil hatte ich damals hier.
Guck mal.
Das war die unsinnigste Platzverschwendung aller...
Na geil.
HiRes.
HiRes-Image.
Ist das nicht vielleicht auch nochmal irgendeine Art und Weise?
Ja.
Na.
Das war die sinnloseste Platzverschwendung aller Zeiten.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das hier ist die...
Aber ergonomisch.
Das hier ist die eigentliche Tastatur.
Es kommt erstmal eine riesengroße Handballenablage,
die ich übrigens sinnvoll finde.
Ich habe hier auch extra für die neue Tastatur eine Handballenablage.
Hier, da.
Habe ich zusätzlich extra gekauft mal vor einer Weile.
Sehr praktisch, muss man sagen.
Handballenablage mag ich.
Aber die war halt da integriert.
Und das hier war so sinnlos.
Du hattest einen Knopf für Browser vor und zurück.
Ein extra Scrollwheel.
Als willst du mit der linken Hand scrollen anstatt mit dem Mausrad.
Damals hatten Mäuse auch schon Scrollräte.
Kopieren...
Copy-Paste-Knöpfe.
Copy-Paste-Knöpfe und ein Task-Switch-Button.
Weil Alt-Tab zu aufwendig ist.
Ja.
Richtig sinnlos.
Das war die Platzverschwendung des Jahrhunderts.
Hier diese Tastatur.
Und da oben hattest du Word, Excel.
Hier.
Guck mal.
Word, Excel, Startseite, E-Mail, Kalender.
Und das haben...
Das haben wirklich viele damals gerne gemacht.
Solche...
...über ausufernden Tastaturen gebaut.
Moin, Dev-Operator.
Danke für 17 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier.
So.
Und kurz weitergucken.
Und das haben damals Komplett-PC-Hersteller auch unglaublich gerne gemacht.
...was often available at retail for the cost of zero dollars.
Was?
That's right.
Ja, das war irgendein Fake.
So nach dem Motto.
Kaufen Sie für 5000 Euro ein, dann kriegen Sie das hier für zero Dollars.
For a handful of years around the turn of the millennium, you could wander into...
Ach so.
Ah, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Du musst 525 Dollar bezahlen.
Du hast einen Rabatt für E-Mail bekommen.
Du hast einen Rabatt für irgendwie anderen Scheiß bekommen.
Und du hast einen Rabatt für deinen Internet-Provider bekommen.
Ja, natürlich.
Du musstest aber am Anfang 525 Dollar bezahlen.
Das war halt immer wieder typischer Cheap Aid.
Und lass mal gucken, was ist denn da drin?
566 MHz Celeron, das war gar nicht schlecht.
Wirklich nicht übel zur damaligen Zeit, ja.
Ein 17 Zoll Monitor, auch nicht schlecht.
Und für 525 ist wirklich preislich nicht verkehrt.
Das ist mit so einem Mediamarkt-Komplettrechner damals zu vergleichen gewesen.
Damals hast du ungefähr 1000, 1200 Mark oder so bezahlt für einen Mediamarkt-Komplettrechner.
Das weiß ich, weil ich habe damals tatsächlich mal einen Mediamarkt-Komplettrechner gekauft.
Also, gekauft.
Gekauft ist zu viel gesagt.
Ich habe so lange Opa, Oma, Mutter, Vater alle genervt, bis ich genug Geld hatte,
damit wir zusammen in den Mediamarkt gefahren sind.
Und ansonsten 32 MB RAM.
32 MB RAM war, glaube ich, auch schon 2000 ein bisschen wenig.
Es gibt 2,5G-Disk.
Das war auch ein bisschen wenig zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
CD, absolut, 56K-Modem.
Ja, gut.
Why not?
Kann man machen.
Integrated Intel, Gedöns.
Nee, Shared, doch Integrated.
Also, du hast zumindest irgendwie einen AGP-Slot gehabt.
Windows ME ist am Start.
Star Office 5.1.
Ja, gut.
Office-Lizenz war natürlich für den Preis nicht mit drin.
Was passiert da auf der Autobahn Richtung Mediamarkt?
Ja, da habe ich ja schon ein Video zu gemacht, was auf der Fahrt zum Mediamarkt passiert ist.
Das ist, Leute, das Angebot ist, also diesen ganzen Müll da unten kannst du mal weglassen.
Aber 525 Euro ist tatsächlich für die damalige Zeit, ist okay gewesen.
Komplettrechner, Tastatur, Monitor, Lautsprecher, vollkommen in Ordnung.
...your big box retailer of choice and walk...
Millimeter DPI ergibt...
Was?
Das I ist Inch.
Was hat das jetzt mit Millimeter zu...
Was auch immer.
...with a complete brand new Windows 98 or XP computer system without paying a dime.
From a certain point of view.
The catch was you'd pay the total cost of...
Ach, Moment, der Monitor hat 100 Euro extra gekostet, okay.
...usually between five and six hundred dollars and then you'd have three or four mail-in rebates to take care of.
One from the store themselves, one from eMachines...
Weiter.
...over the coming months...
...a choice for many if you were seeking a full internet-capable PC.
128 Kilobyte Level 2 Cache.
Als hat das irgendjemand interessiert.
Wisst ihr, als wäre da die Oma in Mediamarkt gegangen und hat gesagt,
Ah, der hat 128 Kilobyte Level 2 Cache.
Das ist das genau, das wir...
Da stand schon sehr viel Schwachsinn drauf.
Guck mal, 64 MB RAM, das war für die damalige Zeit wirklich dann schon ganz gut.
Ich mag irgendwie so Nostalgie-Kram.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich die Zeit, weil das die Zeit war, wo ich so richtig mit Computer in Kontakt gekommen bin zum ersten Mal.
Da war halt dieser Kram hier angesagt.
Ja, so ab 96 angefangen, aber...
...so richtig...
...den...
...das Hoch meines Interesses war halt so auch wirklich in dieser Zeit da, ja.
Weil Boomer, was denn sonst?
Und ich weiß noch, die Celerons damals...
...das waren eher die 366 MHz.
66 MHz Celerons.
Die konntest du so heftig...
...übertakten.
Auf 700 und so teilweise.
Ja, guck mal hier.
Die gingen sonst wie.
Also die waren...
...das war Wahnsinn.
Die konntest du aufs mehr als Doppelte teilweise übertakten.
Und ich hab damals äußerst cringige Newsgroup-Posts gemacht.
Zum Glück, weil kennt keiner meinen kompletten echten Namen.
Und könnt keine Newsgroups danach suchen.
Da waren richtig cringe Posts dabei.
Sigarab-Versionen für ein paar Jahre zumindest.
Aber hey, gratis Computer!
Wenn du schon so...
Dein erster war ein Pentium 90?
Ähh...
Ich glaub mein erster auch.
Ich überleg gerade, was war mein erster Rechner?
Ich glaub der Pentium 90 war der erste Rechner.
So 1996 oder sowas.
Siehste damals...
Damals war die Cebit noch relevant.
Damals war die Cebit noch relevant, aber...
aber wann war denn release date 90 release date 94 ja dann war es eher 95 oder so wo ich den recht
den recht also wie gesagt mein erster rechner war auch ein pentium 90 das war jetzt noch pentium 90
ich glaube es schon ich glaube 16 mb ram das war damals schon krass viel und 15 zoll monitor der
war richtig rotz kann mich noch daran erinnern 15 zoll monitor also das waren das 60 16 mb ram
pentium 90 16 mb ram ich glaube entweder 1,2 g festplatte oder 0,8 g festplatte ich glaube es
war sogar schon 1,2 g festplatte natürlich röhre was sonst war edo ram die riegel kennt heute gar
keiner mehr das war diese teile
ja ja 1,2 1,2 g festplatte pentium 90 und 16 mb ram war das teil grafikkarte glaube ich nicht der
rede wert irgend so ein onboard crap das war auch das sah mehr oder weniger sah das gehäuse halt
genau genauso aus wie bei ihm hier ja und ein startmenü ja gut auflösung war 800 mal 600 es
könnte sogar sein dass mein monitor schon 1024 mal 768 gemacht hat da aber ich glaube das war
damals bin ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher ihr werdet übrigens ihr werdet wahrscheinlich verwundert wie
responsive windows 98 tatsächlich auf so einem rechner gewesen ist die ladezeiten waren bei
allem relativ lang weil magnet festplatte und soja aber wenn das gebootet ist und so das war
wirklich ohne scheiß das startmenü das war schneller als das aktuelle auf dem alten rechner
sign up
so liegt
joktow anyone who knew anything about computers back then of course this was
nothing more than a marketing tactic advertising lefthaus so lieb ja es klar
which for 1999 a month in blutet both mci dial-up internet and upgrade path to a new pc every two
years
all this and the company's history before on lg aber 100 Airport
poi die welche
600 stunden kostenlos sind da hat zudem
das war im prinzip auch bis jetzt ja das war im prinzipisch ist du musst nicht vom internetkor介愛 Weil dieusionszeit von der LTHL alle Cinquanteile der lg wiederhoten auf ätzend ravide mit diesem Ex Ethernet토 weiß ich weiß noch nur fünf du hast du dasopersch sû vessel ist die was hattest du es samholten das ä tanks und von einer Avatar war also meistens schon einmal gezogen und der RCители sind noch so fertig weil es omdat es nicht so fand auch eine Saddler von N'DW noch das aberello hat ihr mit dieser L CP blogs the ASD oder Either ^^
cribed olcd lcsd
HUD мозockt
Du musstest das kündigen, rechtzeitig.
Das ist nicht so, dass es nach 500 Stunden einfach ausgelaufen ist.
Du hattest ein AOL-Abo an der Backe, wenn du es nicht rechtzeitig gekündigt hattest.
Ich erinnere mich noch, Dunkel.
Das war damals schon echt grenzwertiger Scam alles.
Ja, das war das AOL Messenger.
50 Stunden gratis testen.
Ja, genau, genau.
AOL Homebanking.
Wir hatten ja früher nichts außer AOL-CDs.
Ich habe sogar immer noch eine AOL-CD irgendwo.
Ich muss mal nachher durch die Kiste da oben.
Ich habe noch eine Kiste mit alten CDs.
Da ist bestimmt noch eine AOL-CD dabei.
Nigeria-Trended. Warum Trended?
Nein, ich gucke mir keine deutschen Twitter-Trends an.
Nee, nee, nee.
Da darf ich gar nicht mit anfangen.
Ach ja, das waren Zeiten, Leute.
Da war die Welt noch in Ordnung, als ich AOL-CDs gesammelt habe.
Da hat mich nichts gejubelt.
Außer AOL-CDs und Computerkram.
Das war pock.
Wo ist denn das Video?
Soll ich mal ein bisschen was...
Ich will mal ein bisschen reingucken oder so in den Rechner.
Ja, okay, natürlich CD...
Diskettlaufwerk muss natürlich auch sein.
Ohne Diskette geht da nichts.
Aber einen wiederbeschreibbaren CD-Brenner zu haben, war schon eine coole Sache.
Das war die Zeit, wo man sich ja auch selbst noch Musik-CDs und so gebrannt hat.
Hat jemand die Ehre gehabt, jetzt mal so die Boomer unter uns gefragt,
hat jemand mal die Ehre gehabt, mit einem CD-Brenner zu arbeiten,
der, wenn du den Rechner benutzt hast, auf einmal dann kaputt gegangen ist beim Brennen?
Also, die ersten 1-2 Generationen CD-Brenner,
da durftest du den Rechner nicht benutzen, während du CDs gebrannt hast.
Weil, sobald der Brenner nicht mehr konstant Daten schreiben konnte,
weil du hast gestartet...
Keine Ahnung, du hast hier...
Du hast irgendwas gestartet.
No.
Ich will kein Battle.net starten.
Ich wollte irgendwas starten, so.
Und dann hat das Ding underfloat irgendwie die Daten und dann war die CD kaputt.
Tja.
Und damals sahen PC-Gehäuse so aus.
Damals war es auch normal, dass die Dinger innen drin gar nicht abgeschliffen und entgradet und sowas waren.
Du hast dich da auch teilweise geschnitzt.
Ohne Probleme, innen in nem PC-Gehäuse.
Leute, Audio-Jack.
Sachen gibt's.
Die Zukunft damals.
Da hat man...
Heute hat sich Apple gedacht, die Zukunft ist vorbei.
Das gibt's nicht mehr.
Im CD-Drive, klar, warum nicht?
Du kannst ja damit auch ohne Probleme Musik hören.
Wenn du dir das mal angeschaut hast, hast du es schon mal.
Also, oder?
Das hier ist halt so ein bisschen wie ein
Das hatten die meisten.
Das hatten tatsächlich viele.
Hat der hier nicht, aber es hatten tatsächlich viele.
Ah, yes, Diskettlaufwerk.
Wut, wut, wut.
15 pin game
Ja
bleeding edge connections leute
usb
unten joystick port
Nein pentium pentium 19 die hatten alle schon kein turbo knopf mehr turbo knopf hatten die ganzen 486 ja und sowas
port for joysticks in the like
plus stickers all the dag on stickers
besser useful when displayed on a store shelf but they were always there on the case from the factory so it's need to see them
still vermisst den gaming port
warum den warum du heute schließt sowas über usb an ist doch besser als ein komischer joystick port
although and disappointed that the tachy aol 5.0 sticker is missing
rather nasty discolored area on the front of the case
Der hat allen ernstes
ein aol sticker daheim
modern recreation
nice and fresh
Warum hast du aol sticker daheim
gut der macht ja nur so retro kram da hat er halt aol sticker
because their products are awesome anyway round back is the standard io allotment with zero surprises
ps2 usb serial vga parallel
Das hier parallel port sowas gibt's doch
ist manche mainboards haben das noch
Was hast du hier audio geschiss die hast ja heute immer noch die genau die gleichen audio steckers dort immer noch us einen usb anschluss hui hui hui
noch die guten ps2 maus und tastatur anschlüsse
vga und parallel seriell sehe hat jemand von euch die ehre gehabt mal noch
null modem kabel rechner netzwerk technisch per null modem kabel zu verbinden
und das ganze über parallel weil schneller war als seriell
board with undoubtedly mediocre results though this does leave for expansion brackets available since barely anything installed inside
on that note three screws
fällt euch was auf chat fällt euch irgendwas an dem onboard auf was da fehlt
was damals aber eigentlich normal war dass es nicht onboard war da fehlt was oder
findet ihr nicht auch so eine sache viel das geht das wird alles heute irgendwie halbwegs durch gehen aber eine sache fehlt die heute jedes mainboard hat
netzwerk kabel kontakt
korrekt, ja, Netzwerk war damals so gut wie nie Onboard, das war immer per Zusatzkarte
und manche hatten damals auch noch BNC-Netzwerkkarten, so die mit dem Terminator und dem T-Stück,
aber eigentlich, eigentlich zum größten Teil dort auch schon so 2000 rum, ganz normale
RJ45-Stecker, ja, die gab's nicht Onboard, du hast so gut wie immer eine Netzwerkkarte
zusätzlich einbauen müssen, gab's nicht, gab's nicht Onboard.
Was wurde seriell damals genutzt?
Ja, Modems zum Beispiel, Modems, zum Modems anschließen, für Datenaustausch zwischen
Rechnern, aber hauptsächlich für Modems und für alle möglichen Geräte, die es sonst
noch so gab.
Drucker war meistens über diesen bisschen längeren Parallelport, das Beste an den Druckerkabeln
war immer noch das andere, nicht Traktor, das andere, das andere, das andere, das andere,
Traktor, Druckerkabel, die andere Seite zum Parallelport, das war immer noch, das ist
doch kein Druckerkabel, das da, hier, das da, die Seite, die davon an Drucker gekommen
ist, Maus, ja, Maus hast du Serialport angeschlossen, richtig, richtig, genau.
Und damals haben die ganzen Linux-Leute, es ist im Prinzip damals gewesen wie heute, ja,
die ganzen Linux-Leute haben damals drüber diskutiert.
Braucht man Plug-and-Play und USB überhaupt?
Jeder, der einen Rechner verwendet, kann man doch zumuten, Interrupts ordentlich zu konfigurieren.
Im Prinzip die gleichen Diskussionen auf anderer Ebene wie heute.
True, Fifehead, ja, da ist überhaupt kein AGP-Port, das, das hat einfach mal gelogen
vorne drauf, das sind alles PCI-Ports, da ist gar kein AGP-Port, jebaited, normalerweise
hätte der hier oben drüber sein müssen, dort, wo noch ein paar, da ist gar kein AGP-Port,
da ist gar kein AGP-Port, jebaited, normalerweise hätte der hier oben drüber sein müssen,
dort, wo noch ein paar, da ist gar kein AGP-Port, da ist gar kein AGP-Port, da ist gar kein AGP-Port,
sicher nicht der, der hier oben drüber sein müsste, da ist gar kein AGP-Port, da ist
gar kein AGP-Port, da ist gar kein AGP-Port, da ist gar kein AGP-Port, da ist gar keinkaa...
gute Idee.
Jebaited!
Guckt euch mal den CPU-Kühler von damals an!
Damit kühlst du heut, wenn in mit Ach und Krach
Kühlst du heute ein Spannungswandler auf deinem Mainboard, aber noch keine CPU mehr.
Damit kühlst du heute ein Spannungswandler auf deinem Mainboard, aber noch keine CPU mehr.
Na damals hat so'n North Bridge und Lynth Bridge auf dem Mainboard.
Zeug in der Form!
Selbst Mainboards sehen heut total anders aus.
Gut, Spannungswandler hat's da nach wie vor oben druv hier, und Pointe-Pughter Note zur
guck mal, der Anschluss, der Stromanschluss
der ist gefühlt halb so breit wie heute
das ist kein ISA mehr, ja
gut, ISA war ja noch älter
was ist denn da?
ist das der Startknopf?
ich meine, das hier ist Diskette
und das hier ist CD
wo ist denn die Festplatte überhaupt?
ist die hier hochkant?
ne, das ist, ne, hä?
ne, das ist ein
IDE-Kabel, das da oben müsste die Festplatte
sein, hier müsste die Festplatte
drin sein, oder? Das ist ein IDE-Kabel
ach, keine Ahnung
hier ist es, hier ist das Diskettenlaufwerk
unten drunter wahrscheinlich, das müsste, irgendwo
hier müsste die Festplatte sein, irgendwo wo ein IDE-Kabel
lang geht
ach, keine Ahnung
IDE-Kabel
kennt dort auch keiner mehr
einer Turbo-Knöpfe hatten die
damals schon nicht mehr
und wie von Erinnerung
kam es ursprünglich mit 64 MB
von PC-100
SD-RAM
das war ziemlich gut damals
und ich wollte gerade sagen
ich wollte es, was heißt ich wollte es, ich habe es gerade gesagt
ich wollte gerade sagen, also irgendwie
irgendwie habe ich das nicht getroffen, aber ich habe es gerade gesagt
da keine agp slot gesehen geht bei dir ww3 ich weiß nicht ich will mail.ru anticheat nicht installieren
die mäuse damals waren halt wirklich crap wisst ihr was damit was man damals im gaming sektor der
king gewesen ist und nein ich meine damit nicht den fanatic headshot controller wisst ihr was
damals mega geil war die erste razer maus noch mit ball drin ich weiß nicht mehr wie die hieß
die
boom slang genau das war das ding alter riesen fette maus jawoll so war das teil damals aus die
erste gamer maus die es je gegeben hat in dieser form und jeder der was auf sich gehalten hat als
gamer hatte so ein ding und die war richtig fett guckt euch mal die tasten an intelli maus war keine
gaming
maus 2000 dpi leute als als als baum aus das war nahezu filten das war wirklich gut
damals also die macht wirklich wirklich gut kurz danach ging es los mit optischen sensor
mit kugel die hatte noch eine kugel ja guck das ist hier sieht die hatte die hatte noch eine
kugel die des bei die zeigen die gar nicht von adolf jürgen eine kugel und kugelweiße hatten ja auch nach einer zeit immer diese diese ekligen mause
zu machen internet exotika
Diese ekligen Reste unten dran.
Das war absoluter High End.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was es damals gekostet hat.
Preis.
200 DM.
Nee, Moment.
200 Mark hat die erste Gaming Maus gekostet.
Das kostet heute immer noch in Euro.
Das war damals sehr teuer.
Das war wirklich verdammt teuer.
Haudenlukas.de
Von dieser Webseite habe ich noch...
Große Hand erforderlich.
Das Ding war geil damals.
Das war wirklich das Beste, Alter.
Das war noch was.
Das waren andere Zeiten.
Ich sag's euch.
Ja, und diese Mäuse, die mitgeliefert waren,
waren halt Müll.
Selbst 2011 haben Hersteller noch Versuch Kugelmäuse.
Ernsthaft?
Ich glaube, ich hatte es seit 2012.
Oder so.
Keine Kugelmaus mehr.
Ich hatte damals eine...
Moment.
Eine Intelli...
Eine Wireless...
Das war meine erste Intelli Maus Explorer.
Die alte.
Die alte, fette.
Die da war das noch.
Die hier.
Die war das noch.
Das war meine erste optische Maus.
Was?
Review der 2014?
Alter.
Die war 2014 schon 10 Jahre alt.
WTF?
Die Maus Explorer.
Wie man sieht, hat...
Die Maus...
Alter, das war schon 10 Jahre alt, 2014.
...eine Daumenablage auf der rechten Seite.
Oder wurde das nochmal neu aufgelegt?
Zentral.
Noch ein Ticken besser, aber es ist schon...
Es ist schon hart an der Gänze.
Ich hab da mit CS gespielt.
Vor 1.6, Leute.
Ich hab da mit CS 0.5.2 gespielt mit dieser Maus damals.
Weiß ich noch.
War total beschissen zum Spielen damals,
weil die so schwer war.
Und auch die Auflösung richtig mies war
im Vergleich zu aktuellen Maus.
Das ist keine Kugelmaus.
Nee, nee.
Und die Klappe unten nicht richtig fest war.
Was das Problem jetzt von der Maus ist,
und zwar der Empfänger.
Der Empfänger ist...
Ja, dieses Ding.
Herzlich willkommen, lieber Empfänger.
Dieses Oschi, diese Oschi,
der ist echt tatsächlich fast so groß wie eine Maus.
Ja.
Das ist ja von 2004, das Ding.
Wireless Intelli Maus Explorer.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Releasedate.
2002.
Nee, nee.
Ja, ja, so ungefähr.
Na, sag ich doch.
Die Dinger.
Das war...
Pog.
War die erste Wireless Maus, die ich hatte.
Und seitdem...
Also Wireless und Optisch war die Maus.
Wireless und Optisch.
Da muss man sagen, ich habe durch diese Maus gelernt...
Oder ich habe mich vor dieser Maus zu fürchten gelernt
vor Wireless Mäusen.
Und ich hatte...
Bis vor zwei, drei, vor drei Jahren hatte ich noch eine Kabel Maus.
Das hier.
Ich habe aktuell hier Logitech Pro Wireless Maus.
Das ist die erste Wireless Maus seitdem.
Das heißt, ich habe 20 Jahre ungefähr.
Naja, 18 Jahre, 18 Jahre lang wegen dieser Maus keine Wireless Maus mehr verwendet,
weil mich das damals so abgeschreckt hat.
Jetzt habe ich wieder.
Und jetzt bin ich auch zufrieden mit.
Gerade in Kombination mit dem Mauspad, was die Maus automatisch lädt.
Da kannst du nichts zu sagen.
Ist wirklich gute Kombi.
Oh, nice Audioqualität.
Oh.
Guck, das ist auch wieder so eine Tastatur mit so richtig vielen useless, unsinnigen Shortcuts obendrauf.
Banking, Stonks, im Prinzip ist das einfach nur ein Knopf, der wahrscheinlich irgendeine Webseite, vorprogrammierte Webseite aufmacht.
Ah, gute alte Klicky-Klicky-Tastatur.
Ist wieder im Trend mittlerweile.
Ja, es ist wieder im Trend.
Es gibt ja Leute, die schwören heute noch auf diese alten 1980 IBM-Tastaturen.
Das Ding wiegt so viel wie ein Fernseher.
Also wenn du heute einen...
Keine Ahnung, 50 Zoll Fernseher hast, der wiegt ungefähr so viel wie der 14 Zoll Monitor hier.
Jawoll.
Guck mal hier.
Ne, das ist der Input.
Was kann das?
Wichtig, wichtig.
Die Gausen von so einem CRT. Immer die Gausen.
Weiß überhaupt noch jemand, was das ist?
Ja.
Mit einer Max 1024x768 Resolution bei 60 Hertz.
Guck mal, 1024x678 schon.
Gar nicht mal so übel.
Nein, nein, entmagnetisieren ist das bei Monitoren gewesen.
Genau.
Keil 2.1. Entmagnetisieren.
Das ist, wenn du beispielsweise Lautsprecher neben dein CRT gestellt hast, dann haben die, weil Lautsprecher haben Magnete drin,
dann haben die hier den Monitor langsam magnetisiert.
Da hattest du Ringe und sowas.
Und wenn du die Lautsprecher dann weggemacht hast, dann waren die Ringe teilweise immer noch da.
Und dann konntest du den entmagnetisieren.
Dann hat das Bild gewackelt, genau.
Moment, das muss ich...
Für alle, die es nicht kennen.
Die Gaus-Monitor.
Auf geht's.
Guck dir das alte Dell-System an, das XPS-Mos von Sony 15 Jahre her hat.
Weil sie tenden zu produzieren.
Weil das wirklich nicht all so...
Jetzt.
Jawoll.
Das hat auch so einen Sound gemacht, immer.
Auf, die Gaus.
Ah, yes.
So war das.
Ja.
Beste.
Da wurde die Gaus.
Warum hat er ein CRT dran?
An einem aktuellen Rechner?
Ja.
Beste.
Gatschi Bass.
Oh yeah.
Das war nice.
Was genau hat Alman beim Städtetrip jetzt mit D-Gaus-Monitor zu tun?
Man weiß es nicht genau.
...soft and shrunken, so lower resolutions are ideal.
Honestly, even with the light cosmetic damage here and there, the thing looks great.
Especially with low-res DOS-Games and whatnot, all the phosphors on this particular unit look nice and vibrant.
But what am I doing rambling?
Let's move to a comfier spot and get stuck in with the E-Machines E-Tower Experience Circa 2000.
Ah, schöner Quietscheknopf.
Genau.
Erstmal startet das Flugzeug im Hintergrund.
Die waren damals immer brutal laut, die Rechner.
Ah, der gute Post-Piep.
Ah, those little toy speakers.
They try.
Not as bad as a five and a quarter inch drive-based speaker, of course.
But, you know,
...original software and bundled stuff is not on.
Ja gut, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht mehr angucken.
...for the most readable, very simple...
Da ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so spannend.
...in terms of that graphics controller, four megs of memory...
Das war...
Ich meine, eins muss man halt echt sagen.
Viele Menüs damals und Software, die hatten mehr Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten und mehr Settings als heute.
...some kind of...
...on board or shared with the system or what.
It is...
...there, though.
And here's another thing, too.
The mouse, you see, every time I lift it, it like...
Ach ja, und was man bei diesen Monitoren auch machen muss.
Kannst vergessen.
Diese Monitore waren nicht unbedingt gerade.
Also du musstest teilweise wirklich genau einstellen, dass die gerade sind.
Und auch, dass die den Rand richtig ausgefüllt haben.
Aber es könnte durchaus sein, dass dein Monitor so ein bisschen verbogen war.
Und dann musstest du dann quasi mit den Buttons...
...musst du dann quasi einstellen...
...dass Kippen und Trapez-Dingsen, dass das halbwegs gerade aussah.
It scrolls upward kind of a lot.
Like I'm barely moving it just off the pad there.
And it just...
So...
Bisschen viel Maus-Sense eingestellt.
It's just the roller.
The one that goes vertical tends to keep rolling whenever you lift the ball.
So if everything happens like that all the time...
Auf solchen Dingern haben die Leute damals CS gespielt.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
05 oder so.
Maybe the mouse are looking around in the game.
That's why.
So while we don't have the original installation, unfortunately,
the person I bought it from did fill it with all kinds of things to test out on here.
Yay, Ski-Free.
It looks and plays like Ski-Free.
No surprise.
If it couldn't play this, that would be devastatingly stupid.
Oh, it's also got the Microsoft Arcade.
One of these.
I remember playing this...
Oh man.
I guess...
It was an office depot?
Never actually had it at home.
Also ganz im Ernst, das hat man damals auch nicht mehr gespielt, so Zeug.
Das waren eher Games, die sind nochmal 10, 15 Jahre älter.
That's not in battle zone and missile command in particular.
And look, those are only...
I think that's about one meg.
So anyway...
Go and try out a dog.
Würdest du sagen, wenn man nur CS spielen will, lohnt sich ein Röhrenmonitor?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
In der heutigen Zeit würde ich kein Röhrenmonitor mehr kaufen.
Ich meine, es gibt immer noch irgendwelche CS-Leute, die bis vor kurzem CRT gespielt haben.
Ja, aber das passt nicht mehr in die heutige Zeit.
Also wenn ich wirklich sowas holen würde, dann kannst du dir auch ein 1080p 360Hz Monitor holen.
Und dann muss ich ja sagen, die LCD-Bildschirme von heute, die versuchen ja auch ein bisschen...
So dieses Verhalten von CRTs zu kopieren mittlerweile.
Indem sie beispielsweise die Hintergrundbeleuchtung ein- und ausschalten.
Das war ja bei Röhrenmonitoren vom Prinzip her quasi eingebaut so ein bisschen.
Weil du hattest ja keine Hintergrundbeleuchtung bei Röhrenmonitoren.
Der Röhrenmonitor hat ja das Bild aufgebaut hier so zeilenweise.
Das heißt, hier oben ist der Pixel quasi schon langsamer dunkler geworden, bis er dann hier unten angekommen ist und wieder hoch.
So.
Und dementsprechend hat sich das Bild...
Das Bild quasi immer...
Das musste refreshed werden, sonst wäre es halt schwarz geworden.
Und dementsprechend hattest du quasi immer so automatisch...
Bildpunkte, die automatisch quasi ausgelaufen sind mit der Zeit.
Und das versuchen die jetzt ja quasi nachzustellen, schon bei LCD-Monitoren oder bei aktuellen Monitoren,
dass sie die Hintergrundbeleuchtung an- und ausschalten.
So schnell natürlich, dass du nichts davon merkst.
Du merkst es höchstens, dass die Helligkeit ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen geringer wird, wenn du den Gaming-Modus einschaltest oder so.
Nee.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Die ganzen Pros spielen auf Flachbildschirm und die ganzen Turniere laufen auf Flachbildschirm.
Kauf dir einen ordentlichen Gaming-Monitor und gut ist.
Mit CRT würde ich heute nichts mehr...
Nicht mehr rumwursten.
Ja, Bildschirmschoner war damals auch so ein Ding, ja.
Und wisst ihr, was damals schon der beste Bildschirmschoner war?
Da haben die Leute immer...
Ich habe das damals schon immer gesagt.
Und ich habe immer gesagt, Leute, warum verwendet ihr Bildschirmschoner?
Macht den Monitor aus oder macht den Monitor einfach schwarz.
Aber nein, nein, Bildschirmschoner, weil das ist...
Der beste Bildschirmschoner war immer noch Monitor ausschalten oder Bildschirm schwarz machen.
Aber nein, das wollte man ja nicht.
Aber wenn ihr sie runnt, dann wird es entweder direkt das System zerfrieren oder mit einem legalen Apparatus ausgeschlossen.
Und das kann auch in Gotham, um das Bildschirm zu erkennen.
Komm, man hat eine Key in Kickweight.
Ja, es funktioniert nur, wenn man den Sound verschaltet oder es auf PC-Hörer setzt.
Ja.
besser gewesen als ein bildschirmschoner wie gesagt ich habe damals eigentlich immer konnte
es ja unter windows auch sagen einfach monitor schwarz machen ich hatte ihn damals immer auf
monitor manche hatten auch standby modus standby modus gab es damals auch schon bei einigen besser
das war doch was internet explorer na gut den rest müssen wir uns nicht angucken probiert
jetzt irgendwelche sachen aus ich meine es ist klar dass die da drauf laufen warum sollten die
da drauf laufen
irgendwie gucke ich sowas gerne ich weiß nicht das war so die zeit wo ich mich halt so am meisten
für computer kram interessiert haben so ein hardware kram
gemeldet wie jetzt bei mit Kingdom pause da habe ich optimized die progression Women war
die fre Jaguar emotero nicht verstehenEnglish sie sind eine
faszinierende spannen um mehr hat ihr und meiner Tage hat keiner wissen in ko yesterday
wie sollte man dann game play oder game play oder title increases all talking the game and die
millionen liegende oderento und mit rom und princess vielfältig in form von games like you all get your fucking fun kiss APPLAUSE
denn weiss nicht ob er euch mithilfe
check out my other videos on other things that are certainly obsolete but
hopefully I never am I don't know I probably am I don't want to think about
that anyway new lgr videos in the works including the vcf midwest one so stay
tuned for those or subscribe if you like and as always thank you for watching
das war schon ziemlich aber hätte es diese zeit nicht gegeben würde ich heute
nicht hier sitzen die ganzen aufkleber nehmen aber damals stolz auf die
aufkleber am rechner heute habe ich keiner der aufkleber mehr am rechner
das einzige was ich habe ich habe auf meinem arbeits notebook in mongol db
aufkleber fragt mich nicht was mich geritten hat
warum ich dann morgen und db aufkleber drauf haben gab es wahrscheinlich hat
mir glaube ich irgendwann mal eine in die hand gedrückt und ich habe es einfach
drauf gepappt die kanalschienungs aufkleber das ist platoon musik mag
splatoon musik nicht ja alle leute es war echt sein ich
deswegen gucke ich jetzt mal auf die aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber
aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber
aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber aufkleber es erinnert mich so an die zeit für ich
wirklich keine anderen probleme hatte außer die die neueste ct habe ich
damals noch nicht gelesen irgendwas nur ist die games haben ja zu gucken oder zu
schauen was gibt es irgendwie für neue neue hardware und welche cdu und so
damals habe ich da hat ich übelst in plan mehr denn je was rechner hardware
anging da konnte mich alles fragen heute habe ich keine ahnung mehr was
eigentlich ist heute konnte ich nicht lernen hab ich nichts aufkleber gebaut habe ich gelernt mit dem rechner hardware dgu es ging immer mehr setupen und das so und so
aktuelles. Ach, guck mal, das
Python-Buch von
von Algorithmen Verstehen
kommt jetzt raus. Ich hab's grad auf Twitter
gesehen. Ja, Member Berries,
genau, so sieht's aus.
Aber hat jeder so seins.
Wir bauen die stärkste
GPO der Welt in den 100 Euro.
Warum baut der
seine Grafikkarte
mit so nem, ähm,
wie nennt sich diese, diese Sorte,
diese, diese Nüsse zum Schrauben?
Was, warum?
Warum? Wahrscheinlich, weil's gut aussieht.
Unten rechts,
Battlefield, nein, es ist
Containerfield, das wissen wir doch.
Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Weil...
26 Minuten
Battlefield-Rant, das krieg ich selbst hin.
Why you need a Nass?
Weil man
nicht wirklich ein Nass braucht.
Leute, ich geh jetzt auf. Ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss was essen.
Ich futter jetzt paar Nudeln von gestern.
Wird das Battlefield-Video
zweimal vorgeschlagen?
Nee.
Das eine ist
MASSIVE CHANGES
LEVELCAP GAMING
und das andere ist
BATTLEFAIL.
War ein Rust-Projekt.
Wir haben doch letztens was in Rust gemacht.
Das hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was macht die Waage?
Immer noch das gleiche.
Es hat sich so gut wie nix getan.
Immer noch das,
was ich auf Twitter gepostet hab, so,
im Dreh.
Ja.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn. See you.